good morning everyone welcome to
legislative Administration uh can I ask
uh representative Sheen to lead us in
pleaseed the flag of the United stes of
America and to the rep for stand one
nation
individual thank
you a couple of quick housekeeping notes
here um mostly for the committee to
uh to jump on um what I have planned or
what we hope to have planned so um
you've noticed the
time uh looks like there's a gap here um
from the hearings your morning hearings
I don't think there will be um I think
well you've seen um so we have uh but
whatever time we do have available the
Republicans will be caucusing before
lunchtime I believe
um We Have a scheduling issue um with
our our only early bill um the one that
is is uh being heard at 1:00
coincidentally so what I have arranged
is for um 2 o'clock we're going to have
a hard break no matter where we
are um in in the afternoon bills we'll
have a 2 o'clock hard break and we'll be
exacting um that early
bill so that will be um
and then we'll go back we'll recess at 2
o'clock we'll have the quick 5 10 minute
executive session and then we'll go
right back to where we were and keep
going
through
um beyond that then the next hearing
that
I
um oh the next time we will meet I guess
will be and I have to put that in by
noon time um um is it's looking like the
12th March 12th and we'll exact all our
remaining bills at that point you want
to do them all in one day well there's
only um we're running out of time here
you know um that and every time we start
jumping a little bit I don't think it's
a problem um I don't it's not even our
record I mean we can't even break our
record at this point um we had what did
we have 18 last last session so it's
possible to do um but I think um I think
uh we have to get a lot of these things
done before our um our crossover
deadline so uh the 12th looks like the
the next available date it's it's a
Wednesday um and there's a there is some
chance that we will be
um somewhere shortly thereafter going
into two days of session so it would be
Wednesday and Thursday as I
recall
right well not us all but uh yes so I
think that limits between the day that
this room is used the possibility of a
two-day um session week
you get squeezed here along the line so
I think that's what we're planning on
doing um that being
said we
have one two this is prime sponsor if
you hold just a second while we
all right welcome
um the time being past 9:00 um and on
the schedule we have House Bill 142 uh
the chair will call the prime sponsor
representative and chair Michael Mett
Administration thank you Mr chair happy
to be here uh we've been here before
we'll get right to it um for the record
I am represent Mike Moffett representing
marac District 4 the lovely towns of
canterberry and Lowden so this
bipartisan measure as I said has been in
this mix before
uh this version includes some some new
language some compromises that reflect
some earlier testimony and feedback that
the uh supporters have received so the
the flag design is from a National
Organization to be sure uh honor and
remember Inc um it's a nonprofit 501c
there's been some confusion about that
um I also want to say that uh 28 States
28 other states most states have already
uh supported and and um and uh signed on
uh and adopted this flag is something
that these other states um officially
recognize so
uh I understand earlier concerns about
the flag uh one of the big issues was
does this flag detract from the American
flag uh of which I'm also a big
supporter of the American
flag uh yeah yes uh so hopefully the
latest wording of this measure will
better address those concerns my
position is obviously one of support for
uh Goldstar families and and other
families who seek to have this flag
recognized by New Hampshire like most
other states have recognized it and some
of these folks will testify
momentarily um so some of you know I'm a
I'm a history guy and this type of ini
initiative helps keep memories alive and
Spirits alive of our of our fallen uh
will also shining a light on History um
I know the ranking member has a uh his
his ancestors who were Bennington with
General Stark uh my fourth
great-grandfather was at Bennington
General Stark I had never thought about
getting a flag until this year uh just
didn't occur to me but were I to do that
uh my fourth great-grandfather uh that's
one of the things about this flag is you
can put a name on it uh American flag
you you don't do that uh that's would be
seen as flag desecration but one of the
purposes of this flag option is to
personalize it to family
members so and also during a time when
military recruiting has been struggling
up and down uh this type of recognition
since I think we think an important
message that military service
is still valued and that those who make
the ultimate sacrifice will be
remembered so to add a personal not I
was kind of pulled into this effort
several terms ago along with Senator
avard and I was happy to get involved
because uh um I I'm a veteran and I
support veterans I and I try I chair the
veterans committee so anything is
Veterans related I want to understand
and if I can support this is something I
can and have
supported uh and as just said I
mentioned uh I never considered myself
part of a gold star family um but I was
just a couple weeks ago I was walking on
a trail in Canterbury one of my two
towns and uh I was thinking about
putting together some testimony again
for this type of measure and uh as I
just said it occurs to me that this flag
can also honor veterans who weren't
necessarily killed in action um some
veterans
lives their life Journeys are shortened
because of physical or or or psychic uh
trauma that they suffered while on
active duty and I thought of my brother
John I never thought of this until just
a couple weeks ago uh he was also a
marine like myself uh we lost him in
2007 and he left behind a one-year-old
and a four-year-old neither of whom have
any memory of their father he like I
said he's uh buried in bosow and at the
Veteran Cemetery and it occurred to me
like it never did before that an honor
and remember flag with his name on it my
brother John uh would would be someday
uh a wonderful gift to Christian and
Malia and if that flag was officially
sanctioned by this body in New Hampshire
in which we serve then uh it would make
that flag much more
meaningful to the families and to uh and
to veterans
uh so a couple other things much has
been made in the past and again today
that some veteran organizations don't
endorse the flag um you you'll soon hear
from a rep from uh esac which is the
state veterans advisory Council and the
esvac folks are great folks I know a lot
of them a lot of them my friends
there's 20 plus members from all over
the state representing different
veterans organizations last to the
January meeting um just to be there to
answer questions about pending
legislation affecting veterans uh
particularly in the committee I
chair uh and this measure was one of
several that came up and uh I I was not
asked to speak about uh this particular
measure and I in retrospect I kind of
wish I would have thrown my hand up uh
but I didn't know if it was my place I
was there to answer questions which I
did on other bills not not this one
but afterwards and now I I kind of wish
as a veteran I think they may have
allowed me to put my hand up and say a
few words about the measure they had a
brief discussion on it and in the as in
the past svac did not support it and
what uh the main thrust of the
opposition was uh you know we have the
American flag we don't need other Flags
uh oh he needs we get buried under the
American flag and we don't need other
flags to uh to to uh take anything away
from the American flag obviously a lot
of us don't see it exactly that way so
had I been had I been asked to speak or
if I just would have thrown my hand up I
would have taken a couple minutes to try
to share to esvac what I'm sharing with
you about the intent of this flag and
you you'll hear from other people in
just a couple
minutes uh the truth of the matter is
there are a number of flags and symbols
that contribute to our veteran culture
I lead the Lowden Memorial Day Parade
every Memorial Day and behind me is in
the color guard is an American flag and
the P flag and American Legion flag the
legion has a flag U there are many flags
um I mentioned the P flag and all of
these flags and symbols
complement each other as well as they
also complement the American flag in my
view to to create a a tapestry of of
remembrance um a former veteran
committee chair I know the current chair
knows him well uh former representative
from londondary was was a big opponent
of recognizing this flag and he echoed
the sentiments is doing so somehow
detract from the American flag but but
guess what uh his flag the Marine Corps
flag does fly over the state house every
November 10th so his flag flies over the
state house but he didn't doesn't want
and and other folks don't want this flag
to get the same type of
respect so and I can say that as a
marine myself so I I would ask folks
like that former chair from londondary
um why is it okay to recognize your flag
and not this flag
seriously um and I also have toine that
any Bill's prospects are tied to the
committee uh I guess perhaps in the past
this has been around for a while it's
gone to veterans committee I guess in
the past it's gone to this committee at
least twice I'm aware of and uh the the
vice worth this to be in veterans
committee it's a different culture the
the vi my vice chair in Veterans State
Federal veterans is a a gold star father
uh skip Rollins you all know Skip he
couldn't be here today uh he obviously
uh has supported this in the past and
supports it now
uh but it's not in his committee or my
committee it's here so it's this
committee that now owns this measure and
it obviously you know how this all works
you can U do what you're going to do
with it you can amend it uh you can um
do a number of things with or to
hb42 one of the things that has come up
I'm going to finish up here uh last
year's testimony uh somebody pointed out
that it doesn't need to
be there are five days that were
identified as days that it would be nice
to have it uh flown whether at the
cemetery or in the greater state housee
area but it doesn't have to be all five
it could be one or two of those days um
so that's something that you might want
to possibly consider if you do if you
are open to amending it so anyway uh so
the families that have been fighting for
this flag have been doing so for many
years and uh someday they'll be success
uccessful we'll join the other 28 or 30
States whatever it is that recognize
this uh honor remember its
flag um so someday they'll be successful
but uh but why must they wait for
someday why why not today that's my
question why can't we now give them the
Imp perimeter of our great state to
validate their hard work and their flag
their memories their lost loved ones uh
by passing
hb42 uh this year as opposed to some
other year so thanks for all your time
and patience if be have to take any
questions if there are any thank you uh
representative Moffett um are there
question yes uh representative
wall thank you Mr chairman and thank you
represent mfet for coming in to testify
today uh you said that the marine flag
flies over the state house or does it
fly out on the plaza in November
November 10th I believe I I believe it
they it's a day that it's it flies up on
top of the State House this this body
passed uh a measure sanctioning the
Marine Corps flag to fly over the state
house uh one one day a year November
10th uh which I alluded to earlier so
thank
you representative terot thank you Mr
chairman thanks representative Moffett
for your testimony just one quick
question you mentioned you think there's
about 30 states that already have this
do you have listing of those specific
Stat or could somebody get one for me
yeah I got a message yesterday on that
uh the number I saw yesterday was 28 and
this it's pending in other states uh it
was a list of them Virginia
uh okay one of the family members does
have that information thank
you further
questions I have a couple
um is it uh did I hear you say uh that
it doesn't have to be over the State
House it can be in any of the other flag
poles that we have thank you for the
question Mr chair as to how the If This
Were to move forward and the flag would
to be G were to gain recognition uh that
would be up to the committee as to the
days and the sites and the
dimensions uh that's all under your uh
Power at this time thank you um
dimensions are a problem um height of of
the uh existing flag poles that we have
is part of a problem I I'm not I'm not
certain um how the marine flag flies
over the state house I'm not sure if
that um
can um fly without touching the ground
uh quite frankly I'm not I'm not certain
um so it's kind of that may be something
you want to look into I'm also curious
about on line 12 here um
this year's version of the bill says U
shall be displayed daily at the New
Hampshire State Veteran Cemetery in
bosin my understanding from last year's
testimony is it is flying
there than M sh yes the uh the Veteran
Cemetery has certain protocols and
policies where if there's a if there is
a funeral they allow families some uh
discretion in terms of what they display
in terms of days that it may be uh
actually flown officially uh I'd have to
check on with the with the uh the head
of uh the Veteran Cemetery on
that uh do I
understand my understanding is we don't
control the the Veteran Cemetery in
bosin so how would we be saying shall be
displayed daily yeah thank you for that
question uh shall versus May again that
goes to uh the jargon that we're always
dealing with here and if the committee
wanted if the committee were to say may
instead of
shall uh that would uh create some some
leg some leeway uh in terms of here at
the state house uh for whoever is going
to uh hoist a flag or or approve certain
days for example if this committee were
to say uh the committee 5 days course if
this moves forward have to go to the
Senate uh if the committee supported 5
days uh in said May then whoever makes
those decisions would have the
discretion of uh putting it up all five
of those days or one of those days uh if
you limited it to one or two days same
thing only would be one or two days
instead of five again committee has a
whole lot of uh Power here to uh do uh
amend or do whatever you do with it and
yes the uh the I I mentioned Dimensions
earlier and you did as well so I uh I
hate to see uh you know procedural
questions like the dimensions of a flag
or how long the flag pole is be a
showstopper you know if we can put a man
on the moon we can figure out how to uh
uh make the flag dimensions work so that
it could be uh displayed on official New
Hampshire
ground thank you uh further questions
seeing
thank you Mr CH thank
you
ner welcome to legislative
Administration thank you I'm Janine nter
Hillsboro 12 for the record I I hold the
the bill sponsor in the highest esteem
he's one of my favorite people I also
hold the Goldstar families in the
highest esteem um but I do not agree
with this bill um I was a freshman in
2011 2012 when this bill first came to
state and federal relations and Veterans
Affairs and The Honorable Al balero was
chairman at the time the Bill's first
sponsor was then Senator Lou
alesandro one of the people who
testified that day was The Honorable
Fred rice some of you might remember him
he was a Green Beret he fought in
Vietnam and you know who shot at him and
my brother who also served in Vietnam
the Viet Kong and if you look at the
Viet Kong flag you'll see that it
resembles the honor and remember flag
and that was a point of contention in in
the hearings way back then the bill
keeps coming back so I do understand
it's a personal flag and they've they're
not thinking of Viet Kong when they look
at the flag they're thinking of their
loved one and uh we we were never
against um the families having a
personal
flag but um as the honor
um representative um Moffett said um
comparing it to the American flag I I
remember um honorable balero saying you
know um they do have a flag they do have
a flag um to represent them and it's the
American flag it's what's draped over
their coffins when they come home and
that should be the only flag that
represents our servicemen and
women that's it thank you uh questions
sure if there are any are there any
questions welcome thanks for coming
today nope I'm seeing none thank you
very
much uh chair will call
Kevin grappy Grady Grady that's a that's
a
d thank you Mr chairman uh my my
handwriting is terrible I uh probably
should have been a doctor hope I'm not
offending any doctors but um for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I
represent the state veterans advisory
committee um we're actually chartered by
state RSA 115 colon a-8 to uh speak for
veterans and one of the things that we
do is we look through all the bills that
have veteran impact and we take a
position on them then I come and tell
you what that position is as
representative mfet has already said uh
we do oppose this legislation and for
exactly the reason that representative
mfet said we feel like we have the
American flag and that's really all that
we're that we're about we do applaud the
work that honor and remember does they
do a great job with those goldar
families personalizing a flag at no
expense to the family to try and do that
we applaud we applaud their work but we
feel strongly that we already have the
symbol that we need I don't want to take
up any more of the uh the committee's
time because I know you have a lot of
people that want to speak for this
legislation but that's all we have to
say thank you very much uh are there any
questions yes repres I didn't get your
what organization you from again I I I'm
with the state veterans advisory
committee and you can find us through
the dmabs website or 115 colon a-8 is
our is our is the authoriz authorizing
act for uh State veterans advisory
committee well you answered my question
which is can you run that RSA bias again
yes 115 colon a-8 and the members of
this would be members that would be
familiar to you like the American Legion
the Veterans of Foreign Wars I represent
the A and space forces Association there
are 20 member organizations in all in
the
state um beyond beyond the um the point
of the fact that we already have the
American flag for uh are there other
reasons beyond that that um that um none
that have been told to me and I I will
try and make a clarifying point it is my
understanding that since preco this flag
has flown every single day at the state
veterans ver Cemetery in bosan that's my
understanding
okay thank you very much representative
turkot thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking the question um you are in the
room for representative moet's testimony
did um he mentioned I guess he was at a
meeting with you or yes sir and he
didn't speak uh did any of his testimony
have a change your opinion it doesn't
sound like it well if I me perfectly
honest um I I represent the members and
what whatever they decide I have to come
up here and tell you regardless of my my
personal feelings on on this I it's it's
it's a good symbol I I see the pluses
and minuses of it uh on the one hand you
know this this legislation to do this is
coming from out of state it's coming
from people out of state to bring the
same language to the same thing and and
and bringing this in here um you know
trying to get a national presence for
this and they've already got 28 States
according to representative MAA to to
sign off on it we are my my personal
opinion on this is that I I I I could go
either way but but what I have to do is
I have to support our membership on this
and they're and they're pretty adamantly
opposed to it sir H up thank you um
thanks for the additional question uh
you mentioned it was the will of your
membership did was there an actual vote
and what kind of percentage was for
which I I I didn't detect any no votes
all the votes were in in favor of
opposing the legislation so if anybody
actually did not support the legislation
they they either didn't vote or they
no good morning um just another question
your group does that include the
American Legion chapters and the VFW
chapters in the state yes ma'am it
does and a couple of motorcycle groups
Rolling
Thunder that make sense further
questions seeing none thank you very
much uh I'm
assuming um we have uh the husband and
wife owners of the organization or uh
Patricia and Richard with the same last
name so um who wants to go first or do
you want to go together go together Sor
right it's a bigger chair than we used
to have I can stand not problem that's
okay fine whatever you whatever you're
comfortable with just make sure that uh
you can hear we can hear you in the in
the microphone because it does get
recorded um if you could introduce
yourselves that would be great sure my
name is Patricia
Bido my stepson Derek
Bido uh died by suicide on September 1st
2008 he had served in the US Army uh
came home from Afghanistan and was
wounded and
unfortunately um had PTSD and other
issues and again took his own life in
September of
2008 the honor and remember flag is very
special to me personally my stepson uh
lived out in Las Vegas at the time of
his death uh he did not have a lot of
friends he and his family moved around a
lot my husband um and his first wife
were divorced when Derek was very very
young
if this is a way for us to keep Derek's
memory alive and all of the other
soldiers that we have lost throughout
the history of the United
States I believe that this is something
we need to do I am a proud daughter of
two army veterans and I in no way think
that this replaces the American
flag the American American flag that's
presented to families when their Soldier
has died is folded in a beautiful
triangle a lot of people display it in
their home you never take that flag out
again it's never a symbol for us to
recognize that soldier in any way shape
or form there are so many people that
have no idea what a gold star family is
you know people see us wearing t-shirts
after we've participated in a run and
they want to know how they can get that
t-shirt that's a nice t-shirt I want one
of those no you don't want that you know
I speak to my colleagues at work and
they have no idea what gold star
families are if we can present this
honor and remember flag and only fly it
for one day in the state of New
Hampshire on top of our beautiful
capital building and educate people I
think it's more than worth it thank you
thank you I just read what Trish said uh
we have nothing but respect for our
veterans and uh we have nothing respect
for our flag and again this flag is to
remember the people the personal
connection they have with the families
as the goals our family um when I was
working on a career I had many people
that worked for me that were veterans
from the Vietnam War and I was at some
of these meetings before and I brought
up the issue about people had the issue
with the flag looking like the Vietnam
flag or a were the same and every one of
those people that worked for me that
were again that were veterans had
couldn't understand what the issue was
because they had nothing but respect for
what we were trying to do with the flag
to get it into into the state yes other
states have it and I guess we'd like to
be part so good same as the other states
but we want it for New Hampshire it's
going has nothing to do with those that
have served that are still alive which
is fantastic we have a lot of respect
for them this is for the families that
have lost member to their service to our
country and we really believe that
that's something that's very important
like Trish said you know a lot of people
have no idea what a gold St family is
they ask how like said don't what do we
have to do become part of that say it's
not a group you really want to be part
of um questions have come up on other
meetings we've been at before and uh we
believe we've answered questions that
have come up if people have more
questions we'd like to know the
questions so we could address them and
take the fear away some people have
because I know one of the first meetings
that came to the fear was we were trying
to replace the American flag that is so
off course it's it's ridiculous again
we've got a lot of respect for the flag
a lot of respect for all of our military
people who have served like chis said
from a military family I had a lot of
military in my family and a lot of
respect for them and we'd like it to be
considered so that we get the whole
state for the State of New Hampshire to
understand what Goldstar family is and
how much we missed that soldier that we
lost and how much all those soldiers
need to be remembered and not forgotten
that's basically why we're here and why
we want the flag to be represented from
the state of New Hampshire thank you
thank you for your testimony and please
accept our condolences um any
questions seeing none thank you again
can can I just make a couple other
points absolutely sure um we did have a
pla a flag presentation at the Jaffrey
BFW they were very um accommodating and
and we did that a few um a few weeks ago
and also wanted to ask if um testimony
that was sent to you online if that's
something that's been looked at uh yes
it it's received in up until midnight
tonight so typically I and I don't speak
for the rest of the committee but
typically what I do is look at it the
following day okay thank
Youk
thank you Mr chair my name is Jackie gr
and I represent Rockingham 24 the towns
of Ry in
Greenland and one one of my constituents
Nancy
Marston um is a Gold Star Family
mother and I am sponsoring this bill in
honor of her and her family and when one
of my constituents wants something just
like you I try everything I can to make
it happen because I think that we
represent the people of New Hampshire
and when something like this is
requested it should be seriously
evaluated I thought a lot about this
because we testified before you last
year
and the premise was that the American
flag is the flag that should represent
these these um
individuals who don't come
home
and I understand
that but at the same time the Flag
represents all of us the American Flag
represents all the people in this room
all the people in the state all the
people in this
country and the honor and remember flag
represents those people who fought for
pre freedom and are not home to enjoy
it so it's to me an extra it's a blanket
it's an extra
blanket and um we have a flag for those
individuals who are missing in
action but once they're
found there isn't a flag for them it's
and the honorary member flag Inc cases
all of those special people
so I hope that you'll approach this bill
with an open heart and an open
mind and support it thank you so much
for your time thank you uh will you take
questions if there are absolutely
absolutely do we have
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you so much and I apologize
for being so
tardy we are a little bit as stands now
Administration I said Thank you and I
appreciate all of you being here and
taking the time to listen to us I am
Nancy marsten and I am a fourth
generation at least New Hampshire native
as as well as a gold star
mom
um sorry I'm a little nervous so bear
with me it's just us here don't
worry um for 12 years New Hampshire
citizens have requested passage of a
bill to adopt the honor and remember
flag it occurred to me the other day
that maybe we have not been clear on why
this flag is so
important gold star families will tell
you that it gives them peace it gives
them some healing to their grief to see
their CH son or daughter's name on an
honor and remember flag that's true I
fly my flag every Sunday the other six
days I fly the American
flag but the other part of flag is the
fact that it represent excuse
me this flag specifically is to pay
tribute to the thousands of New
Hampshire men and women it's a point of
Pride for New Hampshire when citizens
see the flag flying they say look we
have Patriots who wanted to protect us
who fought for us and who gave their
lives for New Hampshire and the United
States this flag will be meaningful to
everyone in New
Hampshire do you remember there are
1,23 New Hampshire citizens who died in
World War II my Uncle Robert's name is
on the memorial at Hampton Beach this
flag flies to remember him and all of
aunts do you
remember do you need a reminder of the
226 New Hampshire citizens who gave
Vietnam off hand I have three classmates
that I can tell you right now Doug Tom
and Peter work classmates of mine in
conquered High School this flag will
them what about the
399 New Hampshire citizens who served in
the Korean
conflict and did not return home do you
them and recently the glob the global
war on t terrorism has certainly touched
everyone in New Hampshire either
directly or
indirectly 96 so far men and women have
gave their lives they did not lose their
lives they gave their lives for New
Hampshire and for their
country by the way when my son went to
war when all military go to war they
wear the New Hampshire FL the American
flag on their
uniform we in no way want to replace
that aren't you proud of all those New
Hampshire citizens you should be proud
and I believe it is the right thing to
do to show our pride our and to honor
all the military lives
and to
remind every school child every adult
everyone in our state who see this flag
that there were people who sacrificed
democracy in closing I want to say that
sorry Goldstar family's
grief we are the ones who know better
than anyone what will help us we know we
wish the veterans organizations
officially would support the flag but
frankly Goldstar families know what
Goldstar families need better than
anyone and Goldstar family
unfortunately seem to be the ones who
were looking at reminding the rest of
the country of the sacrifices that
made we are only asking for three days a
year to fly this flag Memorial Day gold
star Mother's Day and Gold Star Mothers
three days a year does not sound like
remember I think this is speaking for me
I think 12 years is long enough for
Goldstar families and others who
understand
come before you and advocate for this
Bill thank you very much and I will take
questions thank you um please again
accept our condolences uh one one Qui
quick question I have the the third date
that you mentioned uh families date
right there is is not shown on our list
um when is that so shot can I ask
no phone a friend I'm have you can
uh New Hampshire has its own gold star
Mother's Day which is the Sunday after
Easter there is a National Gold Star
Mothers and families day which is the
last Sunday in September and then
obviously Memorial Memorial Day so those
are the three days that the families are
looking for tell me again the the date
on the on the first one uh New Hampshire
gold star Mother's Day is the Sunday
after
Easter I get you the RSA for that if you
need it
okay thank you very much further
questions please ask please ask me now
rather than going off and talking and
having objections that we didn't even
know to answer representative payer I
was still confused as to why the vet
associations are opposed to this do you
have any other I'm glad you asked that
there are actually veterans several
veterans who sit on the National Honor
and remember board nationally they do
sit on the board um as Trish told you
there are veterans organizations who are
supportive who have received Flags who
this and obviously 28 other states
supportive wait yeah um please accept my
condolences as well um sorry I'm a first
ter rep so I'm missing a little bit of
the context for um the past 12 years
that this effort has been ongoing um so
I was just wondering if you had uh just
a bit of an overview of how this started
or um the reason why this has not passed
if if you happen
topec basically um this is a movement
that as was referred to earlier um is
has become a national movement um a
goldar dad founded the honor and
remember
organization
and and developed the flag as a way to
honor his son and then he decided to
share that
Vision
so people in New Hampshire 12 years ago
learned about this and
um Us in New Hampshire Goldstar families
in New Hampshire have been given
personalized flags three of us here have
those flags that we can't show you
because they're props but um but we have
them and mine has my son's name on it
but to be clear what we're asking is not
for a flag that would have any
individual name on it as I said there's
that but then there's the representing
everyone so the flag that would fly in
the flag that flies every day at the
Veteran Cemetery represents everyone
there's no no name on that flag so
anyway so there's been some as you may
have heard there's been
some
issues that we want to replace the
America you know it's things that we've
addressed it's been it's been tough
because many of the issues are so far
from the
reality and as I said gold star families
know more than anyone what Goldstar
families and what the Fallen
deserve that's pretty brief but I don't
want to go into every single I
appreciate that thank you very much
thank you uh part of that is
um our fault um we tend
to we've we've heard the bill several
times so um it has a tendency and and if
I
recall representative moff had brought
in a history of it in the past did we
not have a
um u a history of the honor and remember
flag in Prior years I speak yes uh we
did submit all kinds of information last
time yeah can that that probably would
be great we can get you something like
that yep great um no further questions
thank you very much for your testimon
respectfully I have one more pink card
uh and that would be for Jean durgen no
Administration have to make an entrance
right
you thank you I won't take much of your
time um you've
heard my Gold Star Family uh they are my
family
speak I am Jean durgen mother of
Sergeant Russell durgen who was killed
in
action uh on June
13th
2006 I am also the mother of three other
veterans my son Sean who is Russell's
twin and just retired from the air
course have a daughter who was in the
Army and she was the only officer in the
family so you know the boys had quite
a difficult time because they they were
expected to salute
her um I I'm here in favor of this flag
and I hold it to my
heart and and the reason it is important
to me
as a gold star mother it's because it
represents my son's
life not just his
death
Russell
was very
much a character
and lived up to his commitment he made a
commitment to his country to all of
you and he kept that
commitment there were other promises
made he he would join um he was actually
um petitioning to be in the State Police
when he was when he would complete
his
tour I didn't know until after he
passed that he made contributions every
month out of his measly pay to an
organization that takes care of children
with
cancer I was proud of
that and I have
continued to make that donation in his
name there were other things that he had
do so we didn't just lose a hero on the
battlefield we lost someone who was
going to make contributions throughout
his life and if you talk to gstar
families you will hear that same
theme their sons their
to
continue to make
improvements the reason this flag is
important to me is because it's not
static it's alive it
moves I can take it with
me I don't in any way dishonor the
American flag and you can probably see
that
um I wear that flag every
day as
well but the reason that I would like to
continue to have the honor and remember
flag
flown is because it
represents the
life not
only the death of my
son and all our sons
and daughters who have made the ultimate
sacrifice uh I didn't write anything out
so excuse me for not
being very articulate but if I had
written I would not have been able to
read it because I tear up and if Russell
were
here he would say don't pay any
did a great job uh would you take any
questions if we have any I I would be
happy to yes questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming today and thank you
all I have one last pink card uh for
Timothy Chron is that right how do I do
close enough um ask for two minutes and
opposes the bill
welcome thank you thank you for taking
my testimony um first I want to express
what I think everyone here feels is the
um complete support and respect for all
the gstar families um and I think
probably in EXA session any new reps
will hear all the arguments from
previous years so I won't go into all of
those um but just for some of the
history um in 2012 I think was the first
year that this bill was introduced and
um in every year um except 2024 it was
introduced to the state um and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs Committee
in 2024 it went to Alle then um in
2012 uh this committee or the state fed
committee voted 11 to1 to remove the
language referring to the honor member
flag from the bill um and so it voted 11
to1 against this
idea um in
2013 the committee voted nine to one
against this this essentially the same
bill the bill has never in any
significant I would say um any
significant respect change from the
original in
2014 uh there were several different uh
bills but
this committee uh state and federal
voted 13-2 and again this is democratic
um houses and chairs and Republican
houses and chairs and a strong Byars
majority each time voted 13-2 against
this
bill on the Senate bill that went
through the Senate um this Comm or the
state and federal voted 13 to nothing
against this
bill and all the these bills all the
recommendations were adopted um on a
Voice vote or presumably on the content
calendar by the full
house um in
2018 uh there was about 14 to nothing to
itl in
uh
uh and uh yes and in 2020 uh the bill
was tabled and died on the table and
rather strange pandemic here we will be
going through all of this um in a in a
written form just if it helps you at all
and uh finally uh this I believe that is
all until last year um when uh
it when it was killed 16 to nothing in
committee um so
there's there have been patriotic people
on this committee and in the state and
federal Relations Committee for well
over a decade looking at and examining
this bill and um I'd hesitate before
suggesting that the vast majority of
them were mistaken and again I just want
to stress my absolute respect for those
who um the citizens who supported this
bill and have find deep meaning in this
flag and uh and I I'm glad that they do
and it's perfectly appropriate that they
do I just don't believe that the state
should be um supporting the private flag
and I don't believe it's makes any sense
to compare this flag to this flag of the
United States Marine
Corps and think that's all I'll take
questions if you have any great thank
you very much uh representative Le yeah
thank you Mr chair um I guess I can see
that there's this pattern that you're
describing um and I've heard a couple of
the arguments regarding veterans
and
associations thinking that this in in
some
fashion replaces the American flag um is
there is that the main argument that you
would say is that your position as to
why you oppose it well there are there
are many essentially it's um asking for
the state government the people of State
of New Hampshire and the government of
the State of New Hampshire to endorse
what is a nonprofit but still a private
flag um a private organization flag we
don't um and to require that it be flown
at uh government the veteran cetar at
government um institutions that is one
thing that seems inappropriate to me
they are able to and they uh the veteran
secretary voluntarily does but to it
seems inappropriate to me to require or
to Grant a state Monopoly essentially or
um State impr premature on a
private not for-profit
symbol good thank you representa s thank
you Mr chair I'm not sure if you would
know this question but do you happen to
know how many different flags get flown
at the State House throughout the year I
do not um and I'm not sure how many of
them if any besides the US flag the New
Hampshire flag and the pmia flag I'm not
sure if any are mandated to be flowing
possibly the Marine Corps flag which is
as you may know the Marine Corps is part
government thank you uh seeing no
further questions thank you very much
for your
help seeing no more pink cards uh I'll
close the hearing on uh House Bill
142 and uh in just a second reset for
here
after
uh we're back uh time being after our uh
schedule time for House Bill 157
I'll open the hearing um and welcome the
prime sponsor um representative
Muntz welcome to legislative
Administration thank you Mr chairman and
um members of the committee for the
just for the record my name is Chris
muns I am one of uh the four state
representatives from Rockingham District
29 representing the town of Hampton
I'm here to introduce HB 157 a bill
establishing a study committee to
examine ways to improve the usefulness
of fiscal
notes now if you're like me you probably
shake your head and roll your eyes
whenever you see a bill recommending the
formation of a of another study
committee and you secretly hope that you
will not be appointed to it when I first
began to consider this issue
establishing a study committee was not
what I envisioned but after talking with
other members and our friends in the
legislative budget assistance office I
do believe this is one instance when a
study committee is warranted and
necessary as members of the general
court we have a constitutional duty to
consider and enact laws and I quote from
part two Article Five of our state
constitution as they may judge for the
benefits and Welfare of this state end
quote to assist us with that
responsibility C certain bills we
consider are accompanied by a fiscal
note again I don't know about you but I
have found most fiscal notes to be of
little use in understanding what
benefits and Welfare to the state those
pieces of legislation to which they are
affixed are likely to have typically
most of them only include a statement of
the impact on the budget of an affected
state
agency one example of why this is not
enough is the replacement of the Canon
Mountain
Tramway the cost of the state to do so
will be approximately 20 to $25
million if that is all that is included
in the fiscal note of the bill to fund
it some of us might be inclined to vote
against it as something that the state
cannot afford not right now with some of
the other budget challenges we
face but that would neglect to take into
consideration the fact that the
Franconia Notch State Park where the
Tramway is located
is the leading generator of revenues for
the state park system not to mention one
of the greatest tourist attractions in
our state and an economic development
engine for the northern part of our
state without the Tramway State Park
rooms and meals and roll toll revenues
would decline blowing a hole in our
state budget but probably even more
devastating would be the fact that some
local businesses would likely close
impacting employment in the region and
local property tax revenues the overall
long-term negative impact of not
replacing the traway would likely dwarf
the one-time cost to do
so unfortunately that kind of full cost
benefit analysis is not something we
usually if ever see when I asked lb LBA
why I discovered the
following RSA 1444 limits the scope of a
fiscal notes to those bills and res
resolutions having an impact on the
revenues expenditures or fiscal
liability of the state city town or
County we have limited their ability to
um to to delve into more um detail RSA
1446 Roman numeral 3 requires fiscal
notes to include quote various
calculations but does not include any
requirement to identify and quantify the
economic benefits that might ACR to the
the city state town or count County if
the proposed legislation is
implemented although RSA 1431 B Roman
numeral 1 uh B assigns responsibility
for preparing fiscal notes to the LBA in
most cases they rely on the affected
state agencies to do the actual analysis
and while RSA 1446 Roman numeral 1 gives
LBA the ability to request assistance
from any source of data they deem
reliable
including but not limited to private
individuals corporations and
associations located within or outside
the state they have limited resources to
tap into that
expertise another major in hindrance
quite frankly is the fact that there are
almost 2,000 bills introduced during a
typical 2-year legislative session since
the current requirement in statute is
that any bill with a possible fiscal
impact of $110,000 or more must have
fiscal note that means by law a fiscal
note must be prepared for over one half
of those bills that volume of work plus
the deadlines the house and the Senate
set for ourselves means that the LBA is
lucky to produce anything let alone
something that provides a comprehensive
analysis while I had hoped to craft a
bill that would establish new
requirements for fiscal notes going
forward I realized that with so many
moving pieces
it would be impossible for me or anyone
single individual to do so in any
meaningful
way this seemed like one instance where
it made sense for a committee of
legislators to get together to decide
what we believe we need to help us carry
out the Constitutional duties assigned
to
us the duties of the study committee
would include at least the
following review and recommend changes
to requirements in current statute for
when or where a fisc note is
required current guidelines for
preparing fiscal notes developed by the
LBA and distributed to the affected
state agencies and current House and
Senate rules to determine if changes in
the filing period for lsrs could or
should be modified in order to provide
more time to complete required fiscal
notes the committee would also determine
whether the current requirement that a
fiscal note is required if the estimated
fiscal impact is $10,000 or more should
be
increased and finally the committee
would evaluate whether the current
Staffing and budget of the LBA is
sufficient to process the number of
fiscal notes the office is required to
provide and also that the state agencies
have the Staffing and resources they
need to provide the LBA with the
detailed analysis and input it requires
for fiscal notes it is required to
complete the committee would consist of
five members of the house and three
members of the Senate
to give the members ample time to
investigate and discuss the options I'm
suggesting that the committee have until
September 1st of 2026 next year to
complete its work I hope you will
recommend this bill is ought to pass and
to remove any fear you may have of being
appointed to committee I will gladly
agree to serve on it uh thank you for
your time and I'd be happy to uh answer
any questions that you may have I was
going to suggest I think you just named
yourself to that committee but that's uh
any uh questions for the represent
representative
way yeah thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for coming to testify so um I guess
my question is it you sort of addressed
it at then in that last portion of your
testimony but um to reiterate given that
OS is already pretty overwhelmed um or
sorry the LBA LBA my bad um
is
already uh struggling to provide
detailed fiscal notes and I do agree
that it would be very beneficial to have
that additional Revenue information
um and yeah I guess you're proposing
that the committee itself would uh see
if if we can increase Staffing um and
other things I I would imagine there are
some things that can be done without
additional staff um I'm just wondering
if this itself needs a yeah no I I what
I what I tried to do was was um give the
study committee the broadest possible uh
range of options that they could look at
and and and one of the things I said is
that the duties of the committee will
include at least the following the I
think it's important that the committee
have the ability to look at everything I
think you know in in essence I think
what needs to happen is that we as
legislators need to decide what is it
that we feel that we need need in order
to do our job and then we need to figure
out what resources are required to do
that um right now we've got a standard I
think that suggests that you know fiscal
notes must be delivered on a thousand
bills but we haven't given the people
that are supposed to do that for us the
resources and quite frankly the time to
be able to do it so something's got to
give
somewhere thank you representative wall
thank you very much Mr chairman thank
you representative for coming in today
and informing us about all this and I
share your frustrations um having been
here for a while I do know that for
example um when I was on the Judiciary
Committee we had a very difficult time
ever getting fiscal notes um but they
were coming through the court system and
that was a real problem I wonder have
you talked with people in the LBA to
find out what their real needs are and
how they might sense uh have a sense of
ction um I did um that's where I started
quite frankly um and as I mentioned in
my testimony I uh I started with grand
visions of you know well this is what we
need to do you know we need to we need
to you know you you and I you know went
to the LBA you need to do be doing this
this this and this um and that's when um
I got an education um and um you know
they had they they enlightened me in
some of the challenges that they face um
and um
um they they they helped me in drafting
the bill I mean they I know that they
can't take a position on the bill uh but
they did help me to make sure that I
wasn't saying something that uh would be
you know completely outlandish um but um
no I did I did consult with him follow
up thank you very much yes quick follow
up um we do have a problem getting
Senators to attend these study
committees have you considered that
that's why I only picked three okay
thank you very much that's ambitious um
I have one question and then we'll let
you go um is there is it your belief
that none of the benefit side of the
equation um comes through in testimony
from the prime sponsor um when they
introduce a
bill I think when when we hear testimony
we get uh we usually get a lot of um
what I would call you know qualitative
anecdotal
benefits um we rarely get the real
quantitative side of things to
um um you know to and and and
unfortunately what happens is on in the
fiscal note the fiscal note tends to
always talk about the
cost um you know in very specific terms
uh but we rarely get in the fiscal node
the offsetting financial benefit um and
um I think without that
information there is a tendency to look
at everything as a cost instead of an
investment that we're making um and um
so so yeah that's that's missing I I I
think it's that quantitative side of
things that U that that's miss that an
object and then the other thing also not
um not to um impune the motives of
people testifying but um you know the
value of having somebody like the LBA do
it is that hopefully it's objective and
not not not not
subjective thank you seeing no further
questions uh thanks very much for your
testimony today thank you uh chair will
call um our Clerk of the house Paul
Smith obviously not taking a position um
but for informational purposes only I
assume yes sir thank you Mr chairman for
the record Paul Smith Clerk of the house
um let me just start by saying that uh
um I I I certainly don't dispute
anything that the uh Prime sponsor uh
discussed with you however there's some
issues that I think that um if you are
going to consider this this passage of
legislation I I think this needs some
work this needs some amending and I'll
and I'll be specific as to why um first
off and the the construction of the
statute uh this is this by the way is a
committee a statutory committee bill um
versus a commission or or that's thing
so this is a chaptered study committee
now uh and in the drafting of this I
note that uh coincidentally this is
drafted in a way that uh is is very um
uh it it's very different and outside
the norm meaning that one member um uh
appointed by the chair that two members
are appointed by the chair of standing
committees that doesn't happen we don't
do that um when it's turn when it's time
for studies the Speaker of the House
historically appoints now in terms of of
regarding party membership um that that
has always been a practice of the house
so uh St you know just in the construct
of this language I'm concerned about the
chairs of these committees having that
appointing authority because that is
that is not Norm operating procedure for
our body um that being said uh because
this is a study and because this impacts
the LBA so
significantly um I would recommend that
the legislative budget assistant be
assigned to this committee um you know
to to to to mandate without actual
expertise from that office being part a
part of that discussion at the table I
think is is is not quite the the product
that you might be looking
for um I want to address a couple of
things and and and and my friend from
Hampton is is a member of the Commerce
Committee and I I bring that up because
last year the Commerce Committee uh
engaged in a cost benefit analysis
regarding ambulance services with the
Department of Insurance now the problem
with a cost benefit analysis is you have
to engage an outside resource to do that
and it took them eight months to do that
so in order to have a a fiscal note that
reflects a cost benefit analysis um
we're we're talking extremely uh
extremely prohibitive times on getting
that information for a fiscal note uh so
that's something to consider in in the
construct of how a fiscal note is
developed um if and having had to write
fiscal notes in the past I will tell you
exactly what what the process is we
receive a worksheet from the legislative
budget assistant we ask specifically the
amount of money that we are uh needing
to spend uh for that program or printing
or whatever the the case may be and then
in in terms of the agencies what their
projected revenue from that might be so
fiscal notes do contain beyond what an
expenditure might be what the projected
revenue from an increase in taxes is and
and I would guide you to look at any of
the bills and ways and means that are
looking to increase taxes and what the
projected Revenue would be from that so
you do get those projections there um
the the other thing that that I'm I'm
the most concerned about uh is the
timing uh in terms of changing deadlines
uh in the second year of the session our
filing period is in September so there
is plenty of time for agencies to get
their work uh you know done and sent
back to the legislature the first year
is always the problematic year but there
are some external and internal factors
that we are constrained by the
Constitution of the State of New
Hampshire says that we're done June 30
full stop so every year the Senate Clerk
and I work with our rules committees and
we build calendars backwards from that
and we are stuck with a certain amount
of weeks because you have to get bills
over to the other body and vice versa
and we are we are constrained by those
constitutional deadlines
um in the in the in the going into the
second year uh excuse me the end of the
bium so filing for the first year of of
of the next bium we give our our
existing members who are running for
reelection an opportunity to file
legislation before the election and uh
pursuant to statute and rule we give our
incoming members an additional time uh
after the election to file legislation
as well but yes there is a deadline and
and but we are constrained by those
those weeks and months built out that
are in the Constitution so it's
important to keep that in consideration
um when you're when you're talking about
uh making recommendations to rules and
deadlines uh from a from a a study
committee um that sure that sounds great
on paper but the reality is we do have
uh we we do have sort of hard deadlines
that we have to and if you look back at
every bium um since we have gone to
annual sessions in in 1984 uh you'll see
that our deadlines and and
representative wall who's been here most
of that time uh will tell you that the
deadlines are generally about the same
uh give or take a week or two every
single bium um now if you want to amend
the Constitution and go to a full-time
legislature like some states I have no
problem with that we could most likely
get some of those uh cvas on on on these
fiscal notes but I I I only bring these
things up in terms of uh your
consideration as as to how you uh look
at the construct of this committee and
what their charges might
be you questions representative
way um so I understand that doing that
more detailed fiscal analysis on a
thousand bills is obviously not
necessarily
um practical um however there might be
some bills that have a very large
Financial impact but might benefit from
a more detailed fiscal note do you think
that this could be structured in a way
where um a much smaller number of bills
would get that um more detailed
treatment or is it more just it would
take months even for a single Bill to
get that detailed analysis um I I I
bring up the issue that was in Commerce
last year because that was a oneoff uh
one-off item and that CBA they it took
them eight months to get it done because
they had to contract out uh to get that
analysis done um and that's why I
brought up that particular issue uh so
that is a one-off issue and and it was a
substantive you know analysis um but I I
will say uh that we do have many fiscal
notes that are developed now uh that are
multiple Pages um that that that do have
a detailed analysis and sometimes uh as
as you may or may not know um every bit
of the and this is another another
interesting thing for your consideration
as well but
um agencies get the drafts of the bill
when OS sends it to
them if a member requests a completely
new redraft during the redraft time um
the
Department of uh Environmental Services
might have submitted a 10-page fiscal
note um but the bill has been
substantively changed now uh in in the
LSR stage and they might have to do a
complete new one so that is that is a a
realistic hindrance uh to them uh
potentially trying to knock things off
in a more uh Speedy rate so to speak um
but uh to your to your specific um I I
do think we have the capability now we
the the state agencies uh L LBA does a
fantastic job in partner partnering with
our state agencies and and getting these
done quickly and effectively um there
does come a time uh and and uh a little
bit behind the scenes uh work here but
there does come a time every year um
when uh it's usually in the first year
because again we're we're that's really
when we have a more truncated time
between the filing and and getting all
the fiscal notes where we might be
waiting and and we send a bill to print
with what we call a generic fiscal note
uh which has the um the the agency is
still working on this note and we'll
send it to the clerk's office etc etc um
and those those do trickle in uh when
they come uh and of course the other
aspect of this and and we changed our
policy um within well it's been a while
now but since I've been clerk where um
anytime we amend a bill um we the the
LBA instantly sends us a new fiscal note
that says this amendment uh will affect
this in the following way um but they
won't
actually a draft a new fiscal note until
an amendment is adopted by the body
because that is the position of the body
um so they are working in concert with
us in in in the clerk's office in OS Etc
to get uh information as quickly and
timely as possible for you sorry for the
thank you Mr chair um obviously it's
gonna be different every year but do you
happen to know the percentage of bills
that require a fiscal note um I I was I
I was a little uh surprised when I saw a
thousand uh needing a fiscal fiscal note
um a year I I I'm not quite sure it's
it's it's that high but but again
anything um and a lot of times you'll
see fiscal notes that say this this has
been uh judged by LBA to cost less than
10,000 a year now in that instance um
they still have to draft it it's so it
still takes time to uh for them to
analyze it uh from OS and they submit
that note back and attach it that means
though that the fiscal note stays with
the bill so any anytime you see a bill
like HB 157 it has that FN that that's
going to exist through the life of the
bill um but that doesn't mean there's
actually a real expense to it um so and
and a lot of times as well uh you all
might make a policy decision to continue
a program and and amend out the actual
funding of it and change it to a dollar
uh appropriation um even though that
doesn't really cost anything in the
grand scheme of things it's still a
fiscal note that um so some of those are
easier to generate and more uh and
quicker to generate then uh some of the
more detailed things but but again in
some of those more detailed things and
and those specific ones for taxes and
and revenues and fees um uh uh those you
know again are are
our fantastic LBA staff um does partner
with you know Revenue Administration Etc
and and and those affected agencies to
to get those uh those hard numbers and
and really they do try to project what
those revenues will bring in um you know
again I I mentioned uh Ways and Means uh
there have been several bills uh offered
this this uh spring so far that that uh
sorry winter it's still winter um uh
that that really do have a lot of those
so no further questions thank you very
much CH will'll call NCH
Grace from
Bia in support of the Bill thank you Mr
chair n Grace for the business industry
Association we are the Statewide Chamber
of Commerce uh we do support this
legislation and that may seem unusual to
some of you um but our me we have over
400 members employing over 100,000
people across the CATE of New Hampshire
and representing about $5 billion in
annual revenues uh and one of the things
that caught our attention was the study
committee's charge to look at the
broader economic impacts of the
possibility of including the broader
economic impacts in fiscal notes um
that's something we'd be very interested
in as you might imagine our members uh
would very much like to know where the
economy is headed uh and that's
something we are very interested in as
well and policy uh determines that to a
large extent so to the extent it is
possible to include that if you go
forward with a uh study committee um we
would be more than happy to come to that
study committee I'm more than happy to
help with that um but that's our
specific interest in this
legislation thank you uh
questions seeing none thank you very
much I have no additional P up um yep if
you'd like to follow up representative
sh couple quick follows um thank thank
you Mr chairman um I I certainly don't
want to take issue with anything that
the that the clerk said uh at all and
yeah I know um but I do think that um
some of the issues he raised is exactly
why I think there needs to be a
discussion uh of you know what we want
going forward so that would be the only
point that I would make and then the
other thing is with regard to how the
members of the committee would be
appointed um my only intention there was
to ensure that um there was some
bipartisan representation on the study
committee and if there's other ways to
do that and not have you know committee
chairman appoint them that's and fine
and and then the other thing was try to
have representation from committees that
you know are maybe a little bit more um
involved with the financial side of
things so that was where that's coming
from and I certainly wouldn't have any
objection to changing that
great thank you not a problem thank you
very
much just want to make sure um no one
else in the room would like to have
chime in on any of this no great uh then
I will close the hearing on
3:31
e
okay we're back uh welcome uh to the
prime sponsor for E glasses House Bill
uh 331 um I think this is actually a
reunion is it
not it is and it's nice to be back thank
you so much and I am also uh in the
distant past sat in that chair so it's
lovely to be here oh I thought you meant
it was this bill which which is also
that's true too yeah no I was uh I was
talking about a reunion to legislative
Administration thank you um my name is
Lucy Weber I am representative for
chesher County 5 which is is the U
Connecticut River Town of Walpole and
it's adjacent town of
Sur this bill is has been before the
committee before it's a relatively
simple transparency
measure it arose when I had a bill that
was very much time sensitive that had to
be passed and in effect by July 1st
because of the start of a fiscal year
for for um commercial appraisers because
it was cons the concern was that without
the bill they might lose their Federal
certification and not be able to
certify um loan transactions
so in any case as as June progressed and
the bill did not come out of once the
bills are passed there's the enrolling
process and the enrolling process is led
by the Secretary of State's office which
gets the bills um to the um Speaker of
the House for Signature and then the
Senate President for Signature there is
the house has deadlines as you heard in
the last
bill the governor has deadlines once
things hit the governor's desk there are
no deadlines in between those things and
quite a lot of that is because things
need to be fluid there are things like
the enrolling process and the things
that the uh ol has to do with a bill um
so I want to make it very clear that
this bill does nothing to change any of
that the process is still the
process all I'm asking is that the
Secretary of State have either on their
website or a link which might make it
easier not have to revise their whole
website to a public facing listing of
where the bills are in the process so if
they're at o Les if they're with the
house uh speaker if they're with the
Senate President um we ultimately
located the bill that everybody in the
Senate president's office that they
didn't have under a pile of other things
on a chair but I had to go and get
somebody from the Secretary of State's
office to come up and show them when it
had been
delivered uh and and
then the the the stuff needed to move it
along so my hope is is that we can go
ahead with that now I I want to
apologize in advance I had fully
intended to talk to the Secretary of
State about this before this time but I
as I just explained to him had a couple
of Fairly serious personal challenges
over the last couple of months which
only really resolved over the last week
two weeks or so so um I haven't had a
lot of extra time but I will be talking
to him the other thing is that I I just
as a matter of History I I initially
thought oh well this is easy it just
goes on in the docket that we keep
anyway which is how you know exactly
where it is when something's in the
possession of the house uh or or in the
possession of the Senate being dealt
with
legislatively but I did have a
conversation with the house Clerk and
his concern is that because it's not in
the possession of the house anymore he
can't
do the docketing necessary because they
don't have control of the information so
that's why it's not done that way and um
my recollection was this was passed by
the house on the consent calendar last
time around I'm hoping that that will
happen again and I promise that I will
go and have many more conversations with
Senators as well in the interim if we're
successful thank you thank you uh
questions repr
thank you Mr chair um so I guess my
question is uh this specifies the
Secretary of State shall publish it um
is there a reason it wouldn't be on gen
Court instead given that that already
has that tracking system that's exactly
what I was talking about when I said
that I I had spoken to the um uh house
Clerk and he'll he's here to testify so
he'll talk more about it but um our
docketing
system is is run in my understanding by
the clerks of the house and the Senate
and at the time that I'm talking about
the bills are no longer in the
possession of the house or in the
possession of the Senate they are being
tracked by the Secretary of State's
office and yes they may be sitting on a
desk in one or the other bodies but
they're not strictly speaking in the
possession of the body they're they're
under the purview of the Secretary of
State who is keeping track in their
office of where all of the bills are but
the only way you can find out where a
bill is is by either calling emailing or
going to that office and saying where's
my bill and I know that for uh the
clerks of the house and the Senate uh
they get a significant amount of um
calls and spend a significant amount of
time just answering the question as to
where the bills are and the answer for
them is we don't know because they're
not in our possession at the
moment follow up um so to understand the
Secretary of State's website and the Gen
Court website sort of have their own
jurisdiction so the Secretary of State
wouldn't even if they have that
information wouldn't have the ability to
publish that on gen Court that's right
that's exactly correct thank you but
they would be have the
ability subject to I'm sure what you
will hear from the Secretary of State to
do it on their website which tracks an
enormous amount of other information and
the reason for my language which said um
on their website or on a public website
link to the public website is the
Secretary of State's office carries an
awful lot of very very sensitive
information and I can't even imagine the
intricacies of dealing with their
website what I'm talking about is
basically an Excel spreadsheet available
to the public so um it's the sort of
thing where if if it's easier for them
to do a link to something else rather
than having to have a consultant come in
and redesign an important and and very
carefully designed
website however it's easiest and most
efficiently done is fine with me I'm
just trying to find a way for the public
and for all of us to be able to find the
information easily and quickly and
without bothering two sets of offices
when uh surely looking it up on the on
easier seeing no further questions thank
you very much thank you all very much
for your attention let's see what the
secretary of state has to say about the
well thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm David scanland
Secretary of State and I'm not taking a
position on the bill I but I would like
to provide some information about the
process and I'll start with the
secretary of state is a unique
constitutional office and that uh
besides us in this in this treasury um
my office has one foot in the executive
branch of government and the other foot
is in the legislative branch and part of
that respon responsibility is when bills
reach the point of transferring from the
legislature uh to the governor's office
for the action by the
executive and so uh we have this process
where once a bill uh receives final
action by the legislature it goes
through the enrolled bills process once
that process is complete the bill comes
to the Secretary of State's office and
we wait until the house member and the
Senate member or a House member or
Senate member of the enrolled bills
committee comes and they sign off on
that piece of
legislation once that occurs we deliver
the bill to the uh speaker of the house
and the speaker can take as much time as
the speaker wants to sign off on the
bill and then it comes back to the
Secretary of State's office and then we
deliver it to the Senate President and
the same thing occurs there now we can
tell where the bill is on the records uh
that we keep and anybody that calls the
office or visits the office and they
want to know where House Bill XYZ is we
can say it's either on the speaker's
desk or it's on the Senate president's
desk um or we have sent it to the
governor we could keep track of that
information on a spring sheet um but up
until this point the legislature has
said no we want to keep the process the
way that it is there may be reasons why
the leadership in the house or the
Senate wants to hang on to a bill at the
tail end of the session uh because we
all know this is a political process and
there are many parts of the process
where there are things that happen
behind the scenes that are not
transparent you may lobbyists that come
and talk to you
individually you know about a specific
Bill and that conversation is offline
but you know they're trying to persuade
you on how you should act on a on a
piece of
legislation both parties have caucuses
both in committee and before the
legislature and those conversations
about how a bill might be handled are
not public it it's inhouse and so this
process of the enrolled bills and how we
keep track of it is simply a part of
that legislative process and from my
perspective it's up to the legislature
to decide how the legislature wants to
keep track of those bills but there may
be reasons why uh
uh you don't want to have it on a
spreadsheet in the open public you know
for everybody to see uh instantly there
may be reasons why uh uh you know that
information is not as readily available
as it could be and with that I'll try
and answer questions representative
Richards uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you um my question is
logistical um and
also I might go into a little hyperbole
as you answer the
logistics um just try the re the
logistic theis but so in the instance
that was brought up where it was on the
chair and you spoke that your office
does keep track of where those bills are
um through the process of moving at the
the those enrolled bills um how would
that individual know is it only memory I
know I walked it down the hall or do
they have um a tracking mechanism um
that is is current that is currently
maintained by someone in your office we
have a tracking me mechanism that is
currently maintained so in that instance
this is where the hyperboy comes in oh
I'm sorry thank you that's um uh thank
you uh this is the hyperbole part um the
pipe
bursts um in the
office um and goes all over that chair
so now that tracking me mechanism as an
as if an archist or something would be
able to say where that bill got
destroyed in some mechanism so we know
that that can be
maintained what we can tell you is from
the records that we keep Who has
possession of that piece of legislation
one more followup followup is that in a
spreadsheet it is not uh maintained
electronically it is not maintained
electronically right okay okay so
there's no ability to back up thank you
got
it representative weight thank you Mr
chair um my question is is there a
reason this process is like an like
paper in the first place and why why
wouldn't you just have a digital system
to send this so you avoid issues of it
literally getting lost in a in a stack
of paper or a pipe bursting or anything
like that is there a reason this
couldn't be digitized
it could be digitized we we maintain a
process of just keeping the records on
paper it has worked for
generations and uh and that's the
process I will add that that my office
does not hold bills uh for an extended
period of time we do not get involved in
you know timing of stuff I mean that
there may be a day or two um before it
goes down to the governor for um you
know signature veto Governor is 5 days
once the governor receives it but in
terms of you know withholding a bill or
delaying it going to the house or the
Senate we do not do that we move the
legislation
along um just in your personal opinion
do you think that this process would be
better if it was
digitized the process as it is working
now has worked over time there have been
no issues with it uh it it could be
digitized and you know that may or may
not be better but um the system that
work I have a question um is uh can you
can you explain the purpose um you've
explained the process of the enroll
bills committee can you explain for um
our our lesser um veterans uh the
purpose of the the enrolled bills
process the purpose of the enrolled Bill
process is to make sure that the
legislation that has
passed has been
uh uh properly passed in other words
once the bill passes both bodies it goes
through a process where uh people in uh
legislative Services is going through
looking for spelling errors punctuation
errors uh maybe statutory reference
errors just to make sure that you know
the language is uh as it was intended
they are not supposed to make
any significant textual changes that
might change the you know the meaning of
the bill it's simply uh it's simply
routine proof reading basically and then
and then the Secretary of State's office
being an independent goete between the
the uh legislative offices and the
governor handle that part of the process
of making sure that each U presiding
officer in both bodies signs off on the
bill you see what I did um
representative payer thank you Mr chair
I'm not sure if you would know this
um okay so I know this bill was in our
committee last year and we passed it 16
to Zer then it went to the Senate and it
was killed there do you know why they
killed it there uh I can speculate but I
don't know why oh
maybe Weber knows later we can ask her
again okay thank you representative
senson did you have a question nope I
think we're all thank you very much
thank you uh last pink I had pink card I
have is for our house of the clerk clerk
house thank you Mr Mr chairman sorry old
habits
um so a couple of couple of quick points
that I I I want to Echo the sentiments
of Representative Weber and and again
thank her for for doing this um and and
I I will say that yes this will increase
transparency in the legislative process
full stop um the fact remains that um I
I am in receipt of documents from the uh
Secretary of State's office when a bill
is chaptered uh that is done uh via a
spreadsheet that is a continual rolling
document um and it also contains the
information on what day it was delivered
to the governor and what day it was
returned from the governor um so my
opinion and this is just my opinion but
adding an additional column of when it
was sent to the speaker and when it was
sent to the Senate President um I don't
think would be too terribly much of a
lift um uh there are documents that I am
responsible personally for posting on
our website that are rolling documents
if you go on to our general court page
and you look at the resignation deaths
and special election page all I do is
update that with the newest version uh
as it as it goes so I certainly think
that this is a a fairly um easy process
that that can be done um after the bill
is enrolled um it really does sort of
enter this black hole and I'm going to
give you an example um in 200 19 Senate
Bill 67 was enrolled uh on June 12th and
it wasn't vetoed by the governor until
August 16th so for two and a half months
it was sitting in the Senate president's
office now during the course of that two
and a half months I received calls
weekly asking where that bill was weekly
um now I don't mind dealing with the
public that's part of my job I love
talking to the public um but the fact
remains that as simple thing of just
putting on the Secretary of State's
website this document that says it's in
the Senate president's office that way
if if if a if a concerned constituent
wants to call and ask Senate President
hey why are you doing this that's fine
um yes there are some political
considerations that that they might be
holding the bill for a bill signing
ceremony which is this happens all the
time um and the Senate it's usually held
in the Senate president's office because
they're closer to the end of the process
than than the house is because the house
Speaker signs it and then it goes back
to the SOS and then up to the Senate
President so the the the Senate
president's office is usually the one
that where it holds for a while um so in
that case uh you know there's there
could be reasons and again those those
are known only to the Senate President
and God not not me um I I would I would
uh mention again yes this bill did pass
unanimously in the house last term uh in
fact I testified in the Senate last term
and the then the new Senate President
now indicated at the time how much she
supported the idea of this bill um and
uh there was a change of heart
apparently um so hopefully we will
change the heart back this year I I
think that would be good thing um uh and
and again uh in terms just to answer
specific questions that that came up
there are log books in each of the
offices um and and I when I say log
books I'm very specific when I when I
mention that each office in the
legislative process has a log book I
have a log book so when a bill is
brought um when when I bring a bill to
the Senate uh that has passed the house
they sign my book when they bring a bill
a Senate bill to the house I sign their
book when I bring a bill down for
enrolling to the secret uh to the um uh
to OS uh they signed my book um when
when we in the committee of conference
process and I brought a bill down there
I have to sign for the bill back so
every and and and similarly when a bill
is brought to the Secretary of State's
office from the speaker and vice versa
the speaker's office and the Secretary
of State are all signing books um so
there is a tracking mechanism currently
it is a hard copy it is a handwritten
thing um but yes it that is the process
uh in terms of keeping that
electronically I you know we do keep the
electronic uh system as it is now
because there is a as I said um there is
a spreadsheet that is prepared uh and it
it contains what the chapter number of
the bill once it's signed becomes what
the effective dates are what day it was
delivered to the governor and vice versa
um so you know that that is a that is a
a part of the process now uh the
secretary mentioned um the process
involving this the SOS uh that is a
relative ly new process in in the grand
scheme of government it started in the
70s that the the Secretary of State's
office became involved in the enrolling
process the 200 years prior to that the
clerks of the respective bodies uh went
directly to uh transmitting the bill to
the governor and vice versa the
Constitution very specifically says when
the when a veto happens the bill goes
directly to the house from which came um
and there has been a delay and in fact
there was a delay under the previous
Secretary of State not this one uh there
was a delay in returning the bill that
that uh from the governor to my Cham to
our chamber where I sent a letter uh
asking specifically should we consider
this enrolled as law now because I had
not received the veto message um so
again uh th those are those are part of
a grander discussion if you'd like to
have one but but uh uh you know again I
think this is a relatively minor piece
uh for for the sake of our constituents
and transparency that that would be a
benefit
I have one question before uh
representative Richards um why do they
call your office and not secretary's
office because they don't know that the
Secretary of State's involved in that
process because
it's that most people don't understand
that the the the Secretary of State who
generally has a
public public facing appearance of being
involved within elections and businesses
and that sort of stuff they don't know
generally um that that they're involved
in in this part of the legislative
process thank you representative Richard
thank you and thank you for taking the
time for clarification for um the
process that you described with the
logistics of signing those books
um the bill that is being sponsored does
not recommend a change to that
historical process no signing that
actual book correct it is just and it
would I did I hear
your good
catch is uh uh did I hear the
clarification that there is that this is
a added digit would you describe it as
an added digitization of that um
historical signing of the book process
uh I I wouldn't because again the the
document that tracks um the the chapter
which the bill becomes uh it tracks when
it goes to the governor and when it's
returned to the governor so it's it is a
spreadsheet and by adding simply a
couple of columns saying to the speaker
to the Senate President uh with those
dates listed on the public facing
website I I that's that's my I think
that's what I was trying to say that
that's digitized but in in essence
that's digitizing you signing the books
no it's it's not and and I I want to
just because uh the secretary brought
this up um in a previous question
statute
requires that everything has to be
signed so all of the bills themselves uh
if uh you all don't usually see these
okay but when you when here's your bill
um your bill is put in a um during the
during the process uh the legislative
process they're put in Orange jackets in
the first year and and yellow in the
second okay uh when and we docket all of
the information that happens to the life
of the bill during the process when we
complete the process and we send the
bill down to the office of legislative
services for enrolling um secretary skin
mentioned the um the enrolling process
now if there's an amendment that needs
to be made that he was talking about
earlier like a correction to RSA
uh grammar grammar fix or that sort of
thing um that is when we will adopt in a
small session of the house an enrolled
Bill Amendment um and that enrolled Bill
Amendment will be made and then the
office of legislative services will take
the final version of the bill and put it
in a red jacket with a cover sheet and
send that to the Secretary of State and
that cover sheet has lines for
signatures and that those signatures are
there has to be somebody from the house
enrolled bills committee the Senate
enrolled bills committee the speaker of
the house and then the Senate President
and then the last line is for the
governor um and so that's that's the
actual physical document that is
required by law uh if you all want to
change that that's another topic I I
wouldn't recommend it because we need
something but uh but but again that's
that's the sort of the
process for policy WS this is the
perfect committee to be in this is no
one else in this building knows how this
works except now you do
um personal opinion it's maybe why this
is uh the clerk's favorite committee um
any other questions further questions
seeing none thank
you having no other pink cards uh I'll
close the hearing on
331 um and as soon as we're up and ready
um we can jump
into 44
welcome representative tersi how are you
I'm good thank you welcome to
legislative Administration I hear you're
here to introduce House Bill 477
yes thank you didn't realize you guys
ran by Senate scheduling time over here
in ledge
admin
ouch actually um for my purposes I value
the committee's time um so rather than
have that Gap waiting while we're
waiting for the time to it's wonderful
for the committee it is it's very
difficult you know it's very difficult
to to know how many people are going to
walk through the door to testify but I
apologize for no I am happy to be here I
happy to be here thank you so very much
good morning thank you Mr chairman again
and thank you members of the committee
I'm Laura tki state representative from
Hillsboro 11 which is Nash's w 8 I'm
here to present for your consideration
House Bill
477 this bipartisan Bill establishes a
commission to study Safety and Security
procedures here in the State House
complex I started thinking about this in
very general terms back in
2023 on November 17th I was returning to
conquered from a meeting and I was
sitting at a red light when a police car
flew by then another and another and
within minutes it was clear that
something horrible had happened at the
time I thought well they're driving in
the opposite direction of the state
house which at the time was a relief to
me but it was about 20 minutes later
when I learned that there had been a
tragic shooting at New Hampshire
hospital this bill is an opportunity to
get ahead of a potential tragedy as a
way to have an ongoing conversation on
Safety and Security as we all know these
buildings are open and filled on a daily
basis with staff legislators and members
of the public and everyone who enters
this space should know that they are
entering a safe
space in July of 2021 the Council of
state governments published an
insightful article titled the state of
State Capital Security which provides a
comprehensive look at the
vulnerabilities and evolving challenges
facing legislative buildings across the
country the article emphasizes that many
state capital structures were designed
long before the modern security
challenges we face today and as such
they often lack the robust safety
features necessary to protect lawmakers
staff in the
public the bill before you proposes a
commission with 11 members from a
variety of Safety and Security
backgrounds and I did receive some
feedback on tweaking the membership if
the committee wishes to do so um to also
include the conquered police chief or
his design the commission would be
charged with studying the feasibility of
implementing safety procedures including
things like the use of identification
badges visitor signin and screening and
safety training evaluating the existing
physical security systems identifying
critical gaps in emergency response
protocols and access control
recommending modern adaptable solutions
that reflect both current and future
security needs learning from best
practices observed in other states and
sectors to build a resilient and
proactive security framework an interim
report would be delivered by November
1st of 2025 with a subsequent report the
following year by establishing this
commission it is my hope that our state
with legislative oversight can take a
measured evidence-based approach to
upgrading our state house security
measures ensuring that our legislative
buildings not only protect those within
but also reinforce public confidence in
the safety of our democratic processes
while this work is taking place in other
forms it is my view that creating this
commission does fill a gap and I thank
you for your
consideration are there
questions I have one um are you aware of
uh any
internal processes that um are perhaps
doing what uh your bill entails yeah um
yes I well I did have a conversation
with um Chris feter um we've discussed
um had a very robust conversation about
it and while he obviously is not
supporting or opposing the bill um he
did say any conversation on Safety and
Security is a good conversation um and I
do know that the um after the shooting
uh the governor did prop um request an
assessment of all state buildings for
Safety and Security um the status of the
legislative complex um that assessment
um has not yet happened the timeline is
somewhat extended as far as I understand
um and I just feel that um there is an
opportunity to have multiple
conversations on
it thank you
um I also sit as the chair of the school
building authority and and that puts me
on the committee called Public School
infrastructure um where we typically are
review doing with Homeland Security all
of the schools uh within our
borders
99.9% of that is um in closed session um
for obvious reasons I
think um you can see perhaps some of the
concern that some of us have with doing
a bill of this type and a commission of
the size that this one may be um is that
something that enters into this I
understand the concerns about um showing
all of our cards to everything but when
we talk about um digging into what other
states do for their Security Buildings
and and what is already out there in
public knowledge I think that there's a
lot to learn um if you look at this
article that I was referencing the state
of State Capital Security I mean there's
a lot of data out there that I think is
valuable to look into um which buildings
utilize you know um visitor signin which
buildings utilize um metal detectors
which buildings require identification
as you enter the building I think that
there's a lot to learn that we're
not letting anything out there to the
public in terms of our security systems
that we have established and I do think
that there um is an opportunity to learn
more and learn from other states in
their pursuit of making sure that their
their complexes are safe so it's not so
much what we're doing it's what we're
not doing no I think that um and I said
this to uh Mr veter that I believe that
um the security team here is great it I
feel that they are moving forward with
even changes in the last few years that
are positive um but I feel it's an
ongoing conversation and I do feel that
um there are maybe some other members
that have had concerns um that there's
always something to discuss so for
example um when knocking around
different ideas just today when I was
walking across the street from the um L
into the state house um a gentleman um
approached the back door as I pulled out
my pass he tried the door and I knew
exactly what was going to happen um I
didn't say anything and he
I said oh you're going to have to go
around and he said well can I just go in
with on with yours and knowing I was
coming into this I said no I would
prefer you wouldn't they monitor the
security on this store right so right
there maybe that is a training situation
I would love to see more training
opportunities with legislators and with
staff in the building you know that has
nothing to do with with putting things
out there but simply making us better
stewards of the safety of our workspace
um another thing is packages and bags
how many times have we all walked into
the Hall of flags and we see piles of
backpacks and coats and everything you
know that's just what we are we welcome
you know communities to come in and and
tour our building but is there a process
for that in case there is a bag that is
left unattended um I'm trying to think
what other ones I already mentioned the
three that I jotted down and then the
only other one was that REM most recent
incident that happened down in um New
Orleans with a vehicle and and building
barriers and you know just what's the
situation with our system you know do we
have um have we taken the best practices
in terms of securing our building and
keeping it safe and are there other
things we can learn
that's okay yeah thank you f questions
represent pay could you send those
documents in your what you wrote to all
of us if you haven't already did you
already say my remarks yeah oh I'd be
happy to and there's um a link to the
article that I reference also okay thank
you representative way thank you Mr
chair um so on on the note of concern of
if we were to undergo this review and
then that would kind of expose what the
security flaws are do these meetings
have to be public record um okay gotcha
just to understand I know you mentioned
that the closed door meetings um in a
different committee that you are a part
of but that's not an option here no okay
rep I'm sorry yes
go two hours um this is also a
procedural question is there a
ability when the session is making
rules um to re
to look at some of the very important
things that you brought up um in
processes each session under rules sorry
I defer to the
clerk uh the clerk has not put in a pink
card but
maybe uh to comment um I also should let
you know that um I've had conversations
with um our coo um Terry PA and um and
um Chris veter and both of them are
in other circumstances and can't testify
today but we will talk to them um right
before we exec the bill so that's good
if that helps thank you Mr shairon I
come from a time this is for the
committee um when this was always called
the people's house of business security
was light very very light and um I
appreciate you're bringing this bill
forward today um I feel great great
confidence that our security
teams um are working together Chris
betterer I understand is recently over
from uh the state police and they're
constantly working on things and I
learned last week we have more cameras
than ever before in places we're not
even aware of um constantly watching the
yeah yeah you're being watched and um so
I appreciate this this is important you
know no matter how much security we have
it'll never be enough there'll always be
some way but I think it's important that
we have an understanding so thank you
for bringing the bill forward thank you
could I just comment one quick thing
absolutely I do want to say that um I
made it very clear with um Mr veter that
this is this bill has nothing to do as a
it's not a statement against his work
the work of our hardworking security
team here I have full respect for them
and I'm actually just trying to help
them in their job and um he and I had a
wonderful conversation about the the
whole thing and the intent of the bill
so thank you for that thank you very
much for your help um and your testimony
um the chair will call Representative
GRE no
ises thank you for the record my name is
Alicia Greg I represent nashaa award 7
uh just so happens that my colleague is
also from NASA I thank her for bringing
this bill before uh you all today so
your your committee room seems pretty
calm right now but uh the committee I
serve on is children and family law it
is not usually that calm just as you
know in U police situations where some
of the most uh dangerous calls they go
on are Domestic Relations uh we have
very high um emotion high risk type of
cases that come before us people that
have you know trying to hold on to their
families and whether not they have made
good decisions with how they bring up
their family or not the desire to hold
on to one's family um I'm not sure
there's anything more as a matter of
fact I sat in this particular committee
room also on the special committee on
DCF I also served on the special
Committee of family courts um we had
particular security concerns and all
three of those um one particular um
individual was known throughout the
state uh as being a security risk from
the U Mayor Don and Manchester to um the
governor's office here he was not able
to um go into the governor's office
anymore including the uh domestic
violence um Coalition across the street
they even had to change how they do
security because of this gentleman he
continued to come into our committee
rooms sometimes had multiple bags uh
would get very um elevated sent a
message to another representative that
he understood why the shooting that
happened in Maine happened because the
legislature was not doing um right by
that gentleman and so that's why that
shooting happened which we call A Veiled
Threat um we had a security meeting with
u Mr faf and some other security members
at that time about you know what our
concerns were because there they had
said that they would be in the room when
he was there they would be there one
time um they actually said that they
have facial recognition on the camera
here which would be amazing but he was
um and I think that's okay but he was in
the building and in our room for 10
minutes before I finally was able to
leave and go get security and they were
shocked that he was there again we have
had people come into our committee room
with giant knives um on their belt and
you know in very heated discussions and
that kind of stuff continues to happen
and while I think that sometimes we want
to keep our security measures quiet and
and I understand that there are a lot of
people that are deterred by having you
know an armed police officer in the room
you know when you understand and we we
actually said that so I was in you know
this security meeting explaining to them
that this is a real deterrent because
what's interesting is in these
personality traits of someone who maybe
um is an abuser in the home or whatever
they have this really interesting tick
where they have a a certain level of
fear maybe going to jail for whatever
reason that is the hierarchy in jail who
knows but they have they have that in
just having an armed officer in the room
makes a huge different it's a huge
deterrent um on that
same token uh you know when you look at
where we are when we are in session and
we have an open space above us that
certainly isn't safe for any of us the
way that it's currently done as a matter
of fact when this gentleman was Contin
to come and contining to elevate you
know I said what what kind of security
do we have up there they said well
somebody's outside the door well so what
happens if somebody's already in that
room and it starts you know we have to
have better watching so they did start
for the next couple times they had
somebody that was you know Security in
you know um in the gallery up there but
I think there are some certain misses
because even though we had this very
long security meeting you know we had um
guarantees that when an individual was
in the building they would make sure
they had somebody there um one time they
were the security was outside the room
and then if something happened they
would come in um another time there were
three other times we had to either call
or we had to um go get security to get
them in there and these are very
elevated situations luckily nothing
happened but that's not to say that
that's not going to happen and my
concern is and my um actually my
gratefulness of having a bill like this
come forward is as legislators hey we're
not paid enough for this kind of um you
know threat to us where we're having
escorts out to our cars or whatever else
but also I think that we have a real
need to look at our security certainly
the political climate is is not
dampering down at all it's gone up we
saw that even with um president Trump
having his um life on the line this last
year and I think it's something that as
a legislature we should be involved
because it's our safety and our lives
that's a part of this I have a uh
somebody I went to school with who's a
republican legislator in Missouri she
was shocked to find out that we didn't
have something like a a signin or metal
detectors for our visitors you know
there are certain things I think we
could be doing and I think it's very
important that as a legislature we take
this step and say this our safety is
important and we do want to take these
steps and I think it's okay if the
public understands that we are taking
more security measures because I
guarantee you they understand what we
don't have right now because they
continue to come in they continue to
spout off saying I know I'm not supposed
to be in the governor's office but here
I am this is an elevated situation and I
think if you're not in these committees
every single day you don't understand we
actually had to have somebody from the
courts have an escort out just a week
ago um because of an elevation in
committee so it our security concerns
are high I have had security
conversations multiple
with the security people here I think
they're doing a very good job but I
think it always helps to have that extra
kind of you know look at what's going
on thank you
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you so much for your
time yes and yes you're up thank you so
much sorry they've literally paused our
executive session so I can run over here
and testify um I am waiting uh thank you
so very much I am Lauren C from the town
of Durham which is the uh straford
County District 10 um I I just want to
Echo my support of the importance of us
looking at safety and safety concerns um
in my first term I uh needed to speak
with my local police department on four
separate occasions based on emails that
I received um I had to I was formally
doxed by uh one of our state uh citizens
um I had to request that my 80-year-old
neighbors keep their um cameras on at
all times so that they could make sure
that no one was approaching I had to
warn my children to be on the lookout
for things um we have challenges I
received another threat Just A Week Ago
um and our state house security has been
phenomenal um and I I see you looking at
me rean with some surprise but the
threats have been or maybe not maybe I'm
misinterpreting but the threats have
been based sometimes based on my
religion um but the most recent one was
because I made a statement supporting
people being vaccinated um not mandating
anything just supporting that and
received additional comments associated
with that our state house people are
fabulous and they work really hard to
get to the bottom of things and share
information but I just feel like we need
to take a deeper dive at a recent
conference in South Carolina with
legislators um from across the
country the level the the difference in
what was offered to people at different
states was incredible um in South
Carolina if you feel unsafe at your home
they'll send State House security to
your house to monitor it and you know
transport you as needed um in other
states they have you know varying levels
depending on the state I recognize we
don't have the resources for a lot of
those things but I do feel that we need
more work done on ensuring that we're
all safe at all times just for
everyone's best
interests further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you
card our Clerk of the
house thank you Mr chairman this was uh
essentially to address a couple of
questions that came up um specific
question came up regarding rules uh I do
want to just be clear that the security
of the
institution uh falls under the purview
of our joint legislative fa facilities
committee I also want to comment that
the building itself and the policies of
the committee rooms fall under that same
committee's purview um that committee
does receive classified briefings that
committee does receive security
assessments from our fantastic security
folks we are we have been undergoing
security situation uh reviews and we are
partnering with our folks over at
Homeland as we speak right now on many
of those issues including drills um so I
I do want to just clarify that the the
the committee The Joint facilities
committee which is a nonpartisan
committee it is the
administrative um Wing that that deals
with the oversight of the building um in
terms of the not only the Safety and
Security but the construct of the new
building behind you uh which hopefully
you'll all be able to park in relatively
soon um but but those uh that is where
um you me you asked about rules uh the
our rules are very specific about
security Personnel in the chamber and I
want to make that clear too there is a
distinction between the chamber and
everywhere else the chamber is under the
direction of the speaker and the
speaker's sergeant-at-arms there is a
rule specifically that says the speaker
can designate an additional security
person for the room when we are in
session and um and that is a a purview
that the the speaker has everything
outside of that falls under the
direction of the joint facilities
committee uh including security
including uh responses and partnering
with other state agencies which we are
doing uh as we undertake these reviews
so just wanted to uh answer that
question and
and thank you Mr chair and thank you
um Mr clerk so just help me on the rule
can a can the body make a rule to
instruct the
bipartisan joint
what because the short answer the short
answer is no the short answer is no
because the The Joint if I may The Joint
Committee on legislative facilities
established by Statute the house rules
apply to the house not to the Senate
which is a co-equal partner therefore
for the joint correct okay that thank
you
for uh underlying that for me um and
that to do what to ask you would be you
know in a point of Education or you
brought up drills or things that would
move us forward um uh to address the
evolving um issues at a time so that was
where I was going with that you
clarified that question but but to that
point representative I I do want to just
mention that there are plans underway
I'm I'm loathed to discuss those uh on
on camera at the moment because we we do
have some some events and activities
that are being planned for the next year
um that that will involve all of you um
but will not be discussed publicly so
follow up just in follow up in the fact
that you know you mentioned the building
being constructed therefore we and and
then there we also know there will be
renovations to this building and so
those all of those things would impact
me so those would be other things for
how do we as the house instruct our
safety through that joint
facility and give a bar to that thank
you
absolutely
s thank you Mr chair how does the joint
facilities committee decide what they're
going to
address uh they they can take up
whatever they want um they uh they have
taken up uh the issue of um uh
earlier today you you saw a person bring
in a flag attached to a pole um they are
the persons that set up the policy of of
what's allowed within the building um so
you can have a placard that you're
holding but you can't have a a wooden um
uh stake attached to a sign um for uh
that those are those are the types of
policies that facilities will determine
they'll also give um as I said they uh
this the staff uh the COO which um
director veter is here now uh director
veter works under the COO um and uh
they're all responsible directly to um
The Joint facilities
committee representative Mr chair um so
given that the joint facilities
committee is established by
Statute um you can't instruct them just
using a house rule to my understanding
so would it just be possible to amend
this bill to say rather than establish a
new committee that um the requirements
under this bill would just be assigned
to the Joint facilities committee would
that be possible I I think you could
amend the bill to say that the this this
is a directive to the Joint facilities
committee to undertake this review um
and and what in instead of dismissing
all of the persons that are listed
within uh the text of the bill uh you
could just say that they would consult
with them
thank I don't see the sergeant-at-arms
mentioned on this listed in I I I
noticed that as well
okay
um I'm not
sure whether I want to
um on camera have uh director vet and
again Mr chairman that's that's why I I
only stepped forward to speak to
representative richards's question
because I there are some things that
that I don't think we need to get into
today um so understand
agreed um I'm not sure there was any
questions I think I would suggest that
if you have further questions you take
them offline um and and discuss them
with director veter um individually and
and if it's something that you would
prefer I attend with you I'm happy to do
but two
um right thank you very much um seeing
no other pink cards I'm going to close
the hearing on uh
477 um we did pretty well on time uh we
are going to be back at
1:00 um PL still exists for this
afternoon um unless there's any problems
concerns and we'll have a uh a caucus um
I guess for the Republicans uh beginning
now um you're welcome to use are you
going to be meeting in this room yes
would you how long do you think your
focus is going to be half an
oh under I'll go with the under yeah we
come back AT3 oh absolutely okay than
you yep uh we won't be back in here
until 1 so you can schedule whatever you
want to
off
e
all right welcome back hope you all had
a nice lunch um we are opening the
hearing on House Bill
314 I will say before we start um this
this bill has a um hard end at 2
o'clock um so I have one two three four
five pink cards and failing that we see
anymore um we will be ending at uh at 2
o'clock so with that I will recognize
the prime sponsor representative
Penza
um if you
could introduce yourself that would be
great and we can start off thank you Mr
chair for the record my name is uh
representative Kelly Penza straford
District 19 um I um I'm just going to
get right into it because I have to go
testify at another bill so basically um
as we know just the definition taxpayer
funded lobbying is where public
officials use public dollars to advocate
for Public Policy uh the blatant misuse
of taxpayer dollars is undemocratic goes
against the free speech of the taxpayer
and is one of the reasons for contining
infringement on the rights of New
Hampshire citizens who we work for and
if I were to guess 99% of the New
Hampshire taxpayers have absolutely no
idea they are funding the expansion of
government to their and their fam's own
detriment how is this a violation of the
taxpayers Free Speech well one it's
compelled speech given that the interest
of citizens May differ from those of
their governments citizens legislative
Lobby efforts towards state State
elected officials might be adversely
affected by the distinct disadvantage
they face when contending with the
agenda of taxpayer funded lobbyists
hired by political
subdivisions additionally these taxpayer
funded lobbying efforts often take
positions contrary to the taxpayers
policy preferences as an example
homeowners may prefer lower property
taxes while a taxing jurisdiction may be
employing lobbyists through an
association to protect or even raise
property taxes is there anything more
absurd than the Department of
Transportation using gas taxes to pay
lobbyists to advocate for higher gas
taxes or the concept of public school
administrators shifting money from
school budgets to pay lobbyists to
advocate for more school funding with a
publicly funded New Hampshire Municipal
Association using resources to reach out
to town Selectmen committees to ADV at
um Advocate against a bill so for
example I'm just going to use some
examples right now on the advocacy page
of the New Hampshire Minal association
website they have a bill Tracker Where
there is a clickable link to their fast
democracy application which states um
either the New Hampshire Municipal
Association supports or they oppose um
right now they support 59 pieces of
legislation and they oppose 109 so just
you know in regards with this committee
um HB 158 uh representative Hill they
um uh HB
584 um representative cero they oppose
your
legislation
hp280 relative to wage payments
representative turkot they oppose your
legislation
so historically and based upon the
preview that I've had of just the
legislation in that one area of their
site um they are supporting and opposing
is usually about four to one favoring
one party the less conservative party
over the other so on their website they
say that they are a nonprofit
nonpartisan membership Association
working to strengthen New Hampshire
cities and towns in their ability to
serve the public as a member funded
member governed and member-driven
Association since 1941 that's all great
I
think I don't know I don't even know
what the percentage is let's say 80% of
what they do is fantastic they provide
Legal Services they have trainings they
have wonderful things but they should
not be taking money from right now which
234 uh pretty much every single every
single town and municipality as well as
54 different districts Villages Village
you know water districts all of these
other things of course counties as well
um to Lobby legislation when their
people don't have any clue what's going
on those are all public employees that
are paying to come go against the
people so right now if you look at some
of the pieces that they say that they
support or post that's all right on
their website happy to send you every
bit of links that you
need it says you know the um nhma
supports funding of state aid to
municipalities supports legislation
authorizing local control over
non-property tax revenue streams and
opposes legislation that reduces
suspends or eliminates existing local
taxes fees or state aid um they have
they oppose an establishment um excuse
me they support an establishment of an
independent redistri redistricting
commission to draw election districts
fairly and without regard to partisan
Advantage think about that that is the
biggest that is that is we're going to
talk out of both sides of our mouth
we're going to say that we want an
independent partisan redistricting but
then again we're going to take money
from public employees and use it to
Lobby against whatever bill s that they
find and usually are against
conservatives in the state there's a
whole slew of other things they support
legislation amending Motor Vehicle
Registration enforcement laws to ensure
collection of all state and local
registration fees owned by New Hampshire
residents they support legislation that
um protects and preserves local natural
resources which is great in public
infrastructure builds Community
resilience um but then they also adopt
into a climate change and they mitigate
risks those are the risks that they set
can can I stop you there for a second
can we talk about um what how this bill
works and how that would how it um
accomplishes your the goals of the bill
okay um so it's fairly simple it
basically takes the the piece the carve
out which is the legislative piece um
and there's many there's you know we're
talking about other associations whether
it be Schoolboard associations um all
that it carves out the piece which is
the lobbying entity of the organizations
so the bill basically stops that so
there's been a lot of emails that I've
received from um public employees uh you
know other estate reps and you know oh
they're concerned that they won't be
able to get this advice or any that's it
doesn't do anything about that it
basically stops the piece that really in
a sense is unconstitutional
and should be illegal so why would I
would never my taxes shouldn't be paying
a lobbyist to go against
legislation that is from the government
it it's the government against the
government it's just it doesn't make any
sense and so this bill does that
specifically it doesn't touch any
aspects of any of these associations and
literally probably a lot of wonderful
things that they're doing um there was a
member when I was a you know last year
when was my or last term when I was a
first year rep and I used um some of the
wonderful resources that they had and
asked um for their expertise in history
and things like that with legislation so
that type of stuff is is great and they
should be providing those trainings and
um they also do um events and a lot of
those types of things that's all great
but when it comes to Orange badge
lobbying for or against legislation on
the taxpayers dime no
and that's what this bill does thank you
uh you'll take questions I assume sure
by uh representa W thank you very much
Mr chairman and thank you very much for
coming in today represent fenza um I
live in a very small town and it's my
understanding that uh the municipal
Association charges different towns
based on population to belong my town
does um we do pay of course towards
lobbying we couldn't afford to pay for a
lobbyist to come in and Lobby on certain
issues and I do know at one time I'm a
former selectman we would receive
notices from the municipal Association
as to what issues they were covering and
we could say whether or not we supported
them um I can you tell me what the
problem is with that maybe the general
citizen doesn't know about us paying his
in all these communities paying into the
municipal Municipal
Association but Our Town fathers and
mothers are managing how the money is
spent when we do become members and we
do have a voice in that do you agree
that that's a
problem the problem is where you just
said um that you have government
employees that are paying to lobby for
legislation
um I get paid $100 a year for this job I
do all of my own work I don't I'm not
asking I I don't gosh I'd love somebody
to lobby for me in all of the
legislation that I want to pass but it's
wrong so if you're talking about advice
or any of those types of things that's
fine but if you're paying someone and
you're a you're Public Employee you're a
government employee or an elected
official that's doing that to another
entity that is then coming in here
that's you're using taxpayer funds to do
that and you can't it's one uh it's
unconstitutional to do that nobody gave
you consent to do
that follow up follow up thank you very
much thank you for your response um that
our town pays about $200 a year to be a
member so the impact on taxpayers is
minimal um should we withdraw from the
municipal Association for all the good
that they do based on the fact that it's
pennies per dollar that anyone pays and
I think it's probably that way with most
communities what do you think no I don't
think that you should withdraw at all I
think that you should utilize all of
their wonderful Services um and if they
want to have a separate funding arm that
is nothing to do that that's what I mean
it has to be separate I don't care if
it's $22,000 or a dollar and there are
fees that are a lot higher of course
with you know larger locations um they
do a lot of great things it's just it
needs to be carved out
specifically prep payer thank you Mr
chair so last year we've we've seen this
bill before HB 1479 last year um a lot
of the testimony we received you
mentioned about a list of certain bills
by certain members of the committee that
were opposed by New Hampshire Municipal
Association as an example so we have a
list of towns that are actually quite
conservative leaning that have submitted
opposition to your bill in Auburn
Allenstown Bedford Dairy gtown Hillsboro
londonairy plasto Salem so how do you
reconcile that why do you spoke I mean
the towns are pretty clear that they
rely on this resource um what is the
conflict
so you just you just basically said that
you just heard from government employees
that want to continue to have taxpayer
funded lobbying efforts that answers the
question I don't care if they are have
conservative reps that represent them it
it really doesn't matter it's a conflict
it's unconstitutional and it needs to
stop it's basically I I gave a lot of
examples and I can give a lot more I
have a lot more testimony but I won't go
there but
you're saying you're you're basically
arguing for them to have access to
something that they shouldn't have
access to if any of these public
employees want to do the work and all of
that kind of stuff on their own and on
their own dime that's fine just like
every other taxpaying taxpaying citizen
would
do can you be you you keep saying
unconstitutional repeatedly what
specific la part of the Constitution
that do you perceive that this prohibits
Free Speech it's
I article
one the first amendment how does that
how does that prohibit Free Speech
because it is consel it's compelled
speech
so to be
specific cons compelled speech is when
the government forces someone to say or
do something that they don't want to do
so because it's government
employees public employees that are
basically lobbying for whatever they
want they're basically deciding on their
own versus their constituents it's not
like they are representing a board of
Selectmen is you know for a town of
4,000 they're not going to those 4,000
people to say hey we're you know we're
contacting the New Hampshire Municipal
Association because you know we really
don't like that bill so we want all of
you guys to be on board that's not how
it's working
you're having a group of people that are
decision okay so it when you're saying
that it sounds like it's cutting off the
knees of people who are elected to run
towns and cities to make decisions
they're these associations make
recommendations they're not saying you
have to do this they're providing
information so this in my opinion is
trying to suppress information to cities
and towns to get more information about
these things because obviously cities
and towns don't have the time and the
resources and the attorneys to di Deep
dive into all of these bills so I don't
think my Selectmen are you know if I had
a real problem with it I would bring It
Forward at my town meeting and say hey I
don't want my town spending money on
this and then we could do a warrant or
whatever I I yes because they were
talking about free speech and I don't
feel like any of this I feel if anything
no question it's not do you agree no I
don't agree because it's not suppressing
free speech for one you just said they
don't have the time so so a a a
selectman doesn't have the time but you
know the father of of six that is
working two jobs or whatever to he I'm
sure he doesn't have the time either so
there shouldn't you're gaming the system
if it comes to all of the stuff that I
talked about the using them as a
resource information training Legal
Services all fine and dandy but when you
are utilizing the
government the government's utilizing um
the government to lobby for itself it's
illegal that it shouldn't be done you're
using it on taxpayer you're funding it
with taxpayer
God so I'm sorry last one so tied into
that would this be perceived as illegal
in your opinion in the house calendar on
December 20th there was a notice by to
attend for representatives to attend an
Alec New Hampshire meeting at the upm
Walker house would that be an illegal a
notice using a public building funded by
tax dollar maintenance a calendar that
is used public money to create is that
bill this doesn't have anything to do
with um that and I don't even know what
Alec is so I can't really speak to that
a notice is not is not lobbying Alec is
a lobbying organization okay well are
they lobbying a bill were they lobbying
a bill were they here testifying
thank you Mr chair um so we've talked a
lot about the municipal side of things
um I'm just trying to understand in
section one paragraph two it says no
public funds shall be used to Lobby
attempt to influence legislation
participate in political activity or
contribute funds to any entity for the
purpose of engaging in the same I'm just
trying to understand the scope of that
we've talked a lot about lobbying
specifically but what would you consider
to be prevented under attempt to
influence legislation would that also
include things like public testimony
from a state
employee no it wouldn't include public
testimony from a state employee it would
it basically if you are a Lobby lobbyist
you have your orange badge and you are
recognized through that one and if so
for example there's a lot of other ways
where social media posts all that kind
of stuff from let's say an association
or whatever that is pushing for um
certain legislation getting people out
to go against all of that kind of stuff
that thank you very
much thank you for your testimony uh
Banfield welcome to legislative
Administration not sure you've ever been
okay uh my name is Amry Banfield for the
record I'm a parental rights Advocate
focused on academic excellence and
education so normally I'm in their
committee so uh I come here in support
of this legislation uh mainly because
everything well everything she said I
would I would agree with parents have no
idea that they're paying for lobbyists
to Lobby on their behalf as the school
board's administrator ation or the
school administrators
Association and then when they come to
find out uh most people are pretty angry
most people don't like that uh why are
they using my tax dollars out of my
school budget where the school's telling
us we need more money and in my time
we're paying $39,000 per student why are
we paying for lobbyists on top of this
um especially since the teachers are
putting into a fund and the teachers are
paying for their own lobbyists so I do
Lobby on have of parents and I don't
wear an orange tag because for 20 years
I've done this and I've accepted a
dime
um they do not represent me and I I'm
going to mainly speak to the lobbyists
that Lobby on behalf of the school
boards of the school school
administrators because that's that's who
will be coming up here um they don't
represent me but yet I have to pay their
salaries and a lot of times their
lobbying efforts go against everything
that I believe in or think that is
actually good for the school and I can
give you a couple examples the school
administrators Association there was a
bill in the house I think by uh
representative cordelli and we had we
looked at the bill and and
um it was to address some of the
pornographic and obscene books that were
given to children on their Chromebooks
through the school library online school
library and we had one person a parent
come in and talk about she was a sex
offender therapist talk about how the
books hyperlink to dating sites where
pedophiles can actually meet up with
children and so this is the kind of
lobbying sometimes that goes on they
didn't want to stop something like that
the school administrators Association
the parent did the parent came in there
was not funded you know just came to
represent herself but that's the kind of
conflict that happens with these
organizations they're not representing
parents lot of times but yet the parents
are forced to pay
them um another thing I thought of
because I know that this has come before
your Committee in the
past and representative Penza had talked
about compelled speech if this is not
acceptable if you are not willing to
restrict this kind of activity then it
should be all activity I haven't P been
paid for 20 years and yet I've
represented parents every year in
conquered so why don't we just take the
money that the school is spending
because now it's budget neutral put it
into a a a trust fund and then let other
people with different viewpoints start
taking money out and and start paying
anybody who has a different Viewpoint
why is it just limited viewpoints that
get the taxpayer money that's that's the
other thing so I'm looking at possibly
maybe an amendment maybe you guys can
come with an up with Amendment if this
isn't acceptable to the committee
because I think it's acceptable I think
it should just be done away with I think
you know schools need money and yet
they're throwing money out the out the
door for this stuff um why not come up
with an amendment and I'm working on
language with an attorney right now that
you throw it all into a pot trust fund
and then let other people with different
viewpoints take out and and they are
able to Lobby on behalf of parents and
students special needs we have special
needs people who come here all the time
they're not paid a dime and so you know
why why is it just restricted to some
viewpoints I guess and and so that might
be an alternative to the to this bill um
I think that's basically what I wanted
to say uh school board's administration
had put out a model policy years ago
they withdrew it but it it had a
provision in it where information was to
be hidden from parents
parents don't want this a lot of parents
don't want that I'm certainly not
speaking for everybody but a lot of
parents don't want that and yet they're
paying for that so that's those are the
situations that I've seen for 20 years
and something's got to be done I mean
because to me when parents find out that
this is going on they're not very happy
about it so that's all I wanted to bring
you thank you very much for your testony
uh will you take questions sure are
there any questions for Miss bfield
seeing none thank you very much you uh
call E glasses um Margaret burns from
nhma ask for five minutes and opposes
Bill thank you good afternoon members of
the legislative Administration committee
my name is Margaret Burns I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association I'm here in
opposition to the bill
I've been executive director for seven
years now and each one of those seven
years we've seen a bill like this almost
each one of those seven years we've seen
a bill like this and as was referenced
earlier House Bill 1479 which was
substantially similar to this bill was
inde definitely postponed there's often
a lot of mixed information about what
these bills do and there was certainly a
lot of mixed information about what last
year's Bill did as well as what this
year's House Bill 314 does so I'd like
to break it down what the impacts are of
the actual bill as
written the bill prohibits a wide range
of individuals from speech related
activity in relation to the legislative
process it's sort of broken down into
two different
prohibitions the first two paragraphs
paragraph one and paragraph two are
extremely broad by adding the term
public funds into RSA chapter 15 and
defining it as any Grant or
appropriation of the state or any local
government and then Banning in the
second paragraph that any public funds
can be used to Lobby attempt to
influence legislation or participate in
political activity there's essentially a
complete ban on any form of speech that
is in any way funded by public funds
this is because an appropriation of
public funds is simply that it can be
someone's salary it can be mileage to
travel somewhere it can be the phone or
the computer that's used a public funds
appropriation is simply money
appropriated by the state or local
government for a particular purpose so
adding in this new definition of public
funds and coupling that with the
prohibition in paragraph two that no
public funds can be used for these
purposes is going to impact not only
organizations that Lobby and and people
who register as lobbyist but much
broader than that it's going to affect
all local officials as well as anyone
Who's acting in any capacity that's
funded by a grant or appropriation of
the state or local government and so
that's why paragraph 1 and two are Broad
and they don't just relate to lobbyists
and they don't even just relate to
lobbying activity because while lobbying
at least has some type of definition in
RSA chapter 15 the additional terms
attempt to influence legislation or
partic participate in political activity
are incredibly broad so at worst these
create complete banss on speech related
to legislation and at best they create
Mass confusion about what speech is
allowed which will have the effect of
chilling speech in this
legislature and for that reason although
most of the testimony introducing the
bill was focused on the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and on local
governments there is a very wide range
of groups and individ ual who are
opposed to House Bill 314 some of them
who you might have heard from already
this includes the New Hampshire for
Center Center for nonprofits the New
Hampshire charitable Foundation
Association of Cy School boards
Association of assessing officials
Health officers associations Public
Works Public Works Mutual Aid police
Chiefs Fire Chiefs and so on paragraph
three is really a separate prohibition
from paragraphs one and two paragraph
three is focused specifically on believe
organizations that are recipients of
public funds and has a separate
requirement that those organizations
have to segregate funds so I believe I
heard when the prime sponsor introduced
the bill that this bill is prohibiting
lobbying activity because it is
unconstitutional speech but in fact
paragraph one and two are broadly
prohibiting in general local officials
and others who are funded by public
speech from speaking and being part of
the legislative process process and then
paragraph three is creating some sort of
separate requirement for segregation of
funds by certain organizations
specifically those that are required to
register under RSA chapter 151 so two
separate prohibitions that are both very
Broad in their
effect and of course the bill goes on to
make these activities a Class A
misdemeanor there's personal liability
that is equal to three times the amount
of money um improperly used um and any
person in the state has the ability to
bring that lawsuit whether they can show
direct harm or not or whether they're
directly connected or not they would
have the ability to bring the
lawsuit what this bill really is doing
is it's creating a Broadband on speech
and it is also at the same time going to
create a serious chilling effect on what
speech nh's lobbying is very public and
as you saw in or as you heard about in
the introduction of the bill all the
bills that we take positions on are
posted on our website we are very
transparent about what we do and how we
do it and in the past we have heard with
respect to this bill that much of the
support for bills like this is because
people don't agree with the positions
that we take here in the legislature and
that we would they would prefer that we
don't take them what disturbs me most
post about the information around this
bill is that our positions that we take
on legislation should somehow have an
effect on whether or not municipalities
local officials and other individuals
who wish to speak and engage in the
legislative process should be banned
from doing so nhma is a nonprofit
nonpartisan organization our positions
are solely based on what our members
vote on through our legislative policy
process every two years we do not take
into account party we do not take into
account anything except how the bills
impact local government we have heard
many times on this bill that part of the
problem allegedly is that the advocacy
we do is somehow not in the interest of
New Hampshire taxpayers and I wish to
tell you that that is patently false
most of the bills that nhma takes
positions on do one of two things they
cost taxpayers more money and they take
away voter Authority at the local level
by taking away local control while it
may or may not be true that individuals
across the state understand that there's
advocacy happening on the behalf of
local governments the majority of the
bills that we're involved with would
cost taxpayers money or would affect
their ability to vote and make decisions
at the local level and while this bill
on its face is not about that the speech
that it would ban as a result is serious
and would have seriously detrimental
effects on the train transparency and
access to the legislative process that
you all engage in so I urge you to vote
this bill as in expedient to legislate I
apologize if I was more than five
minutes it's all right we'll bill you
um would you take questions of
course short ones right look at the
clock um representative payer thank
thank you Mr chairman can you tell me um
just out of my own personal curiosity
what is your background do you have a
legal background yes I'm a yes I'm a
lawyer and before I was executive
director of the municipal Association I
was staff attorney there for several
years you have a you have a follow oh
follow I'm sorry you have some
familiarity with the
law I ask one more follow question last
one okay so from what you were talking
about that this would be a ban on speech
and whatnot in your legal opinion is
this a violation of the First Amendment
um lobbying is protected
speech so so there are serious
constitutional implications by this
Bill thank you any further question uh
representative Turk thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking the uh
question you mentioned nonprofit I'm
just curious what is the total revenue
nhma takes in from all the
municipalities in New Hampshire are you
asking total revenue of the association
or total du's revenue I can give you I
can give you both sure um for 2025
approximately 1.3 million in total dues
Revenue that's 234 cities and towns and
50 something associate members total
budget for the association for 2025
approximately 2
million thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
very much for your
testimony chair will call William
McKinny uh New Hampshire
building if I can read that maybe you
can do it building officials Association
yes sir yes sir three minutes I like
that um opposes the bill I'll do my best
on keeping my time thank you so uh thank
you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm Bill mckenny I'm
representing the New Hampshire building
officials Association as their past
president and current legislative
affairs chairman um the Hampshire
building officials Association is a
nonprofit professional association that
represents over 200 code officials
throughout the state of New Hampshire
the language contained in H House Bill
314 was has been introduced in several
of the last few sessions I I think I've
testified um for you know in favor or
against or whatever different versions
of this um o over the past four or five
sessions so to my knowledge each session
uh the Committees have recommended itl
and uh I believe that was for good
reason the term lobbyist in
rsa5 uh colum one has a very broad
definition and combined with a past uh
State's Attorney General's office
opinion it would Encompass many
professional organizations and
associations whose their intent is to
educate not to Lobby we're often called
here by the the Committees to speak on
behalf of our positions on bills just to
provide you with more information many
professional associations such as nhoa
receive payments from communities for
their code officials to be members to
attend our valuable trainings and our
meetings the fees for membership to
those associations are currently
within the annual budgets of those of
the communities that the voters review
and approve whether it be through town
meeting deliberative session or through
town or city councils there is a
transparent and public process already
to approve these funds in each Community
within our state the Hampshire building
officials Association also represents
our members by providing input to
legislators on bills that may have a
positive or negative impact to building
and life safety Cod in New
Hampshire NHA and other professional
associations are often requested by
legislators to provide input for from
our members relative to legislation
specific to our areas of expertise many
smaller communities do not have the
staff or resources to have their voice
heard and conquered those communities
rely on the many professional
associations to speak on their behalf on
matters of great importance the many
professional associations do not receive
funding specifically for lobbying nor do
they intend to Lobby however again
because of the broad definition we get
rolled into that and especially with
this
bill how will House Bill 314 impact the
minicipal employee who wishes to educate
legislators on the merits of legislation
will this legislation prohibit those
conversations unless discussion time and
funding is tracked this proposed
legislation could limit or even prohibit
free discussion and free speech of
Municipal Employees with their
legislators House Bill 314 while it is
well intended to Target specific
lobbying expenditures or groups and to
provide additional transparency could
also have far-reaching negative impacts
and ramifications to many valuable
professional associations and Municipal
officials that helped to keep costs for
New Hampshire lower and with that I'm
willing to accept any questions he did
pretty well at the time uh anyone have
questions I have one uh does your
organization allow for um a member to um
purchase some services but not but not
lobbying um is that an option for a
member
town again one of the services that I
would say that we do not provide we do
not provide lobbying our our members
when we come to speak here are on our
own time however we're speaking on
behalf of our um code officials but the
money for them for those members to be
part of our association even if I'm
testifying before you today could be
misconstrued as tax faay punding funding
for lobbying correct because I'm I'm
obviously trying to provide information
that may sway what you feel about this
legislation and by the definition and by
an opinion by the prior State's Attorney
General's office then that becomes
lobbying great thank you very much for
your help thank you and I appreciate no
further questions thank you for your
time free to
go the last pink card card the last pink
card that I have for this bill um is uh
a t a twofer um Jason Henry and Kathy
barui um are testifying together
apparently I they actually put on the
cards
but you're welcome uh we do have time if
you want to do
singularly okay please introduce
is oh thank you hi um my name is
Katherine Barby I'm president of the New
Hampshire registry of deeds
Association and um the registers um
unanimously oppose House Bill
314 um it is the position of the
registry ad Deeds associ iation that if
House Bill 314 were passed that it would
censor those who may have the most
information regarding a proposed Bill
the registers of Deeds take an oath of
off an oath um upon taking their office
to discharge their duties to the best of
their abilities it is submitted that
providing information on a bill that may
affect the daily operation of the
Registries is part of the duties of the
register of deeds the registry of deeds
Association maintains that it is the
duty and the responsibility of the
association to work with Committees of
the general court to provide information
on how a proposed Bill may affect the
daily operations of the registry of
deeds offices how it may affect the
public that uses the registry of deeds
offices and local County government
ultimately after receiving this
information it is a responsibility of
each legislature to consider this
information and to vote his or her
conscience this bill if passed will take
away the ability of those who may have
the most information regarding a bill
from
testifying especially with the way that
the bill is drafted I mean obviously
we're not specifically we're not
lobbying group but we feel that we have
information hopefully that's important
um dealing with the records um land
records and property records uh real
property records and how the those
offices are run so two examples that the
New Hampshire registry of deeds
Association um has taken a position on
in this term it for example is the
Amendment on the transfer on death deed
statute and on the proposal to create a
landlord registry within the New
Hampshire registry of deeds offices the
testimony information provided to the
legislative committees by the New
Hampshire registry of deeds Association
provided substant information so that
each committee member's vote could be
more well informed um if House Bill 314
we believe is passed that it's going to
muzzle those um they're best able to
provide information on the topic of bill
that is before a committee therefore the
registry ad Deeds Association is asking
that house bill 314 um be voted in
expedient to
legislate thank you uh would you be
willing to take questions of course are
there any
questions I have one yes um are you
aware in 15 colon one of the definitions
of lobbyists uh it exempts uh testimony
before committee the concern that that
we had with the bill the way that it's
written that I I think was addressed by
the former speaker um the attorney
representing believe the municipal
Association is how that it's written
that that may be interpreted differently
in the statute um that it appears to be
that anyone who is coming to testify who
is maybe on um you know the time that
you know being paid for mileage or being
or coming to testify taking time from
work to do that might be then um subject
to the um the fines and the penalties I
believe it's a misdemeanor so that's a
concern that the registry of deeds
Association has with this bill great
thank you very much for your answer
thank you um yeah representative way
yeah thank you Mr chair um so to sort of
follow up on that one is it to your
understanding that when it says um no
public funds shall be used to attempt to
influence legislation or participate in
political activity that that would
include public
testimony um for any employee that is
paid by state funds yes that's our
you seeing none uh thank you very much
thank you um so now my question is uh
does Jason Henry
um okay be great if we could get one
pink card for each of you
thank
you good good afternoon everybody um
Jason Henry I'm superintendent of
Rockingham County Jail uh I'm also
legislative chair for Hampshire
Association of counties and representing
them I'm also a school board member as
well too so I will I concur with most
the testimony already happened in front
of us my concern on this bill also is
attempt to influence legislation uh I'm
appointed official I'm concerned that it
would I would create a misdemeanor by
influencing it's not just here
testifying I get called
the last minute from house members
senators and everything else for my
expertise on certain things I think
there's a missoma on how the um CM
lobbyist or how these groups work so for
us we have a superintendent affiliate
registered Deeds we meet as 10
superintendent we look at these bills
which are help with our um call them
lobbyists to compile them and we best we
uh stewards of taxpayer dollars look at
is it going to affect how much it's
going to cost so we can reasonbly make
decisions and come down here and
testify then if we want to take a full
stance on something it's not just
individuals it's a group and then from
there we go to our executive committee
executive committee is made for us five
members from each one of the counties
who have to take a full vote on how we
wish to present down to here whether we
want something it or we support
something we support plenty of bills
back and forth too so I think people
concerned that there's not voices aren't
being heard they're being heard by the
experts that are in the field and as
some you with other Wards and other
things that's what you elected for
appointed for be a expert in the field
and I'm concerned that would stifle the
information be given to you guys any uh
funds be used for any lobbyist I'm sure
that New Hampshire spent some money down
in DC because you can't be there every
day helping back and forth so would this
prohibit that kind of behavior or
whatever people want to call it
opportunity for you guys to receive
information I don't know I but I'm very
concerned about the bill Association of
county in general is opposed to this
bill um we opposed it in the past
I don't waste your time because
everybody else spoke on the other stuff
I'll take any questions thank you are
there any questions I have one um you
mentioned that you your executive
committee I think you said has a has a
member group of five five Per County F
Per County yeah um I'm not going to do
the math there so um what I'm assuming
there's there are often decisions that
are not unanimous correct um how does
that
how does the minority get their voice
um expressed here it doesn't stop
anybody from coming down in testifying
whatsoever it's as an association itself
we may say this but there are times that
you can go down and testify that may be
against because it is five and
representative it could be Comm
Commissioners nursing home directors
superintendent anybody we may have
opposing that does happen once in in a
blue moon we try to talk it out and get
on the same page but doesn't stop them
from coming down and testifying in
position or for something PR each other
counties or they they're representing
granting myself a followup um does that
necessarily mean that the um that both
sides would be coming and testifying
from your organization or would they
would one be testifying as an individual
and and the majority would be testifying
from your organization or how how does
so when we do vote that's a majority of
the organization and again so that
individuals could come down and testify
individually against it and sometimes
when we can't come to consensus we don't
vote to say your unanimous incen down
and how we feel we a lot of bills we say
that is up to your county up to your how
you feel and those kinds of things so if
we can't come to you I never don't come
unanimous consent on something we just
say then go down on your own and what
works for your individual County because
some of these bills impact different
areas differently so there are some
bills we just do not take a stance on
okay great thank you very much for your
help no further questions thank you well
um it it looks to me like uh people
listen to my admonition that we are
going to end at uh exactly 2 o'clock um
is there anyone in the room that would
like to
testify seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on what is this 314 34
34 and we have 10 minutes or so
what's
the representative home you are before
you sit down
um I only have your pink card do you
know if there's other
testimony okay so here's my um and I'm
not sure if the Secretary of State plans
on
testifying um we have a hard break at 2
o'clock if you think you can you've got
five to 10 minutes in here
um do you think that's
reasonable okay otherwise I would have
you wait till like quarter past two or
so but if you want to go you're welcome
to go and I'll open the hearing on 546
and uh and welcome the prime sponsor
representative
uh do you do you have another pink card
coming for they're right over there got
him thank you okay thank you Mr chairman
for the record representative Bill M
Hillsboro 10 city of nashwa first I'd
like to say that the original bill is
drafted doesn't work and I have a
committee amendment that greatly
simplifies the bill and that may be
sufficient uh under state law not to be
required so the problem I'm trying to
solve is
uh to have disclosure of of campaign
contributions of $1,000 or more and as a
Secretary of State's office has pointed
out to me under new legislation that was
effective January of this year after my
bill was originally drafted seems to
cover most of that
requirement and specifically the
6646 uh talks about a 48 hours reporting
period for contributions of $1,000 or
more which solves most of the problem
that I'm trying to address here the only
open issue is whether it's whether some
reasonable reporting by The Secret of
State's office without doing a lot of
administrative overhead to give a
summary of these reports uh to the
public and that's my
testimony thank you uh
questions I have a couple are are we
getting an amendment is that what I
understand
up here we go yeah um and this does this
amendment replace the entire Bill
correct it replaces the entire bill it
simplifies uh sections and it talks
about just reporting of a campaign
contribution of $1,000 or more which may
be covered under uh the new statute that
took Effect generary one is um is this
going to mean additional reporting or
replace existing reporting it would be a
distant reporting of the uh existing
forms so now there's a requirement
report every six months December 30th
June uh 30th uh for campaign
contributions um I'm hoping that we can
get more prompt reporting on these major
contributions if it's not going to be a
lot of work for the Secretary of
State um last question for me um is
the existing reporting is done on paper
um by representatives and online I
Believe by Senators um that would remain
in this bill as well right yeah I've not
changed the reporting uh procedure okay
all right um no further questions thank
you very much uh does the yes I have a
pink card um deputy secretary of state
Aon Hennessy thank you Mr chair members
of the committee my name is Aaron
Hennessy I am the deputy secretary of
state can I just confirm what amendment
number you're looking at yes it looks
like uh 2025 D2
0253 okay thank you so last year the um
house election law committee had a
summerlong session of rewriting some of
the campaign Finance laws and what they
did was try and make it easier for
people B to report it's still very
voluminous election law um chapter
664 but um I believe what representative
om is trying to do is to add a an
additional report if you if you receive
,000 contribution any time during
December between the time of December to
January that you would have to report
that within 48 Hours the law which was
HB 1091 of 2024 took away the 48h hour
report the previous 48 hour report only
related to I believe was a $500
contribution within 48 Hours of an
election it's no longer in law so I
can't remember now it's gone um but I
think that was his intention um but I do
want to say that the way this
amendment's written um it doesn't quite
do that um and would only apply to
candidates and not to political
committees some candidates Rec uh sign
up register with our office as a
candidate committee which is now
considered one of the political
committees so this should really be if
if you agree should be in section
6646 and as the chair pointed out um
state representatives are not required
to file their campaign Finance reports
with our office electronically through
our campaign Finance system so the
requirement of us doing a monthly report
to the legislature on these donations
would have to be a lot of man hours from
our office which we do not have right
now um unless you want to give us some
more people um because we would have to
manually go through each of the paper
filings and summarize them each
month I'm happy to take questions thank
you are there questions I have one um is
there a plan in the future
for um electronic filing for
Representatives is that there in the in
the law and I don't remember what the
the law states I think it's next
election cycle so the 20 so after this
election cycle ends which just started
so two years from now I believe that's
when State reps may have to start using
mandatory file online some State reps
already do file online through the
campaign Finance system
but so it's coming it's coming would
that would that change um is this
premature I guess is that what I'm
saying um that that would definitely be
a lot easier for our office because um
if everyone did their campaign Finance
Reports online then just a summary
report could be generated by anyone not
necessarily from our office however we
would need to work with our vendor to
create systematically the requirement
for that report um because that's not
one of the reports that's done right now
so there would be an expense to that I
can't guess what that would
be um last followup
is is your testimony um wrapped
into um the Ethics Committee testimony
or does that have nothing to do with
your concerns on this bill that has
nothing to do with
me I'm just about campaign Finance piece
yep represented payer thank you Mr chair
just to clarify what I thought heard you
0253 um under section two it says each
candidate and I thought I heard you say
you suggest that be also political
committees too include or did I get it
wrong thanks for the question so this um
this section of law refers back to the C
the calendar of campaign Finance reports
that political committees have to do so
if you're going to change when somebody
has to file a report it should shouldn't
be in
6647 it should be in
6646 section one one of the little
letters so so I'm clear candidates are
in
seven candidates are in seven but
they're reporting
requirements um the line 15 of this
amendment refers to 6646 134 and those
the reporting requirements which are the
ones that the political committees have
to do think I got it
uh further questions followup
no um I think I'm set thank you very
testimony think we're going to have do
you know if um your fellow sub is H way
he's here he's here yeah I know he's
too I think we're still good right you
count roses one two three four five one
two one two three four five six right
one two four five six yeah all right so
I'm going to
uh yes I'm going to um close the hearing
did I close the hearing
on we lost it
yes
um and I am going
to recognize a motion from uh
representative
turot thank you Mr chairman uh like like
to make the motion of retain on HB 314
representative turkot moves retain on
House Bill 314 is there a second second
seconded by uh representative shien uh
discussion briefly okay uh yeah just
briefly um I think
U we'd be rushed since it is an FN Bill
we prefer or I prefer to uh have a
little more time
to amend if that's if that's the way we
decide to go I know we I've heard a lot
of testimony today that would uh tell me
we if we're going to attempt this that
we need to uh do some amendments so I
think retaining at this point is the
best best option for us thank you
representative turkot I will just say
that um just to reiterate some of the
concern that we have um is not our fault
um we have a calendar to deal with and
um and House Bill 314 as
constituted um would be considered an
early Bill meaning that it is going to
go to a second committee
um by retaining it um we have solved
that issue um and it also gives time for
us to um then look at this bill uh for
next term
um and see if there's things that we can
take from it or or we may meet as a as a
committee of the whole which is what we
typically do um or um in subcommittee
but it would be this bill in its present
form would be not non-existent until um
we're in another building thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for this motion um
we have a question on timing when might
we work on this what uh do we have
some thank you for your question we
um as the as the clerk likes to say um
not in this building so when we move um
we would be taking this up probably
September or
so representative payer hello I'm just
curious what's the second committee that
we would send this to I I'm assuming um
because there is a uh we're all set
actually now we've got yeah we're good
to go is it thanks for your help is it
Finance is that what you meant um I
think no because it's not really a
financial issue I think it would
probably go to criminal justice would be
my guess but okay I was just curious um
that's that's probably my least favorite
part of this whole bill so if that gives
you any indication any so um the motion
on the floor is um retain on House Bill
314 and I will ask the clerk to call the
role chair she in excuse me
representative
turot yes represent pet Pell I can't see
that
yes representative Boyd yes clerk votes
yes representative wall yes
representative
Richards yes representative P yes
representative senson yes representative
Wade yes and the
chair chair vot yes 11 yes zero no all
right
um we are unanimous uh we are done with
the executive session on this thank you
with that um I promise 10 minutes we're
out in five um we're now back onto our
regular schedule and we can open the
hearing on House Bill
605 which is relative the employment
protection for members of the general
court represent uh recognize the prime
sponsor representative Reed welcome to
legislative Administration thank you Mr
chair thank you honorable members of the
committee for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10 new
market in new Fields thank
you um this is similar to bills you have
seen in the past including one bill that
enjoyed quite a bit of support on the
floor last
year it has two parts I was trying to
work with my colleague um regarding both
of our bills and we didn't manage to
coordinate our language like we
originally intended through OS but I'll
go through the the first part first and
if the committee to divide out and and
take out the second part that's also
something I would
support So as you may recall the Public
service loan forgiveness program is a
federal program that was created under
the George W Bush Administration in 2007
the intention of the Public service loan
forgiveness program is to encourage
young people to enter Public
Service the program only applies for
federal student loans it does not apply
for private student loans and to qualify
a person must make 120 ontime payments
while they are employed in public
service and that definition is very very
exact um once those 10 years of payments
are made while in public service um if
they are approved any of the remaining
federal student loans after those 10
years of payments is Forgiven um public
service is defined in the statute the
federal statute as either nonprofit work
or any governmental work in the United
States including federal state local and
tribal so any government um position in
this country um as well as nonprofit an
applicant uh can qualify with various
types of Public Service kind of cobbled
together so you might have two years in
public office four years teaching um a
couple years with the dot you can put
all that together to qualify for those
120 ontime payments
there are lots of rules around the
Public service loan forgiveness program
um for example certain governmental
contractors count other contractors do
not count when Congress passed this
program they very explicitly Exempted
only themselves only Federal legislators
so as to not have a conflict of interest
they did not very intentionally did not
exempt any uh state legislatures in fact
most of the states to um certify their
public servants their legislators as
public
service the form that an employe
employer receives to qualify that
person's time working there as public
service has essentially six lines uh
that includes the name and address of
the uh employer the start and end dates
of the service the EIN number the
employer identification number um and
the um yeah which the federal government
then goes by to determine whether the
organization qualifies
so New Hampshire state legislators are
paid a BAL salary of $200 per the state
constitution part 2 Article 15 the EIN
number and I actually this is from last
year but this is my last
terms W2 for my State
Legislative uh work $200 the EIN number
02y 60000 618 is the same employer
number that any state employee in this
state has if you are working as a road
crew member for the dot if you are
working for the fish and game department
um members behind me have the same exact
EIN number because your employer
identification number I understand that
we have a narrative in the state and I
appreciate it that we are a volunteer
legislature that we are uh not
technically employees and that's fine
how we have things is fine but as far as
the federal government's concerned
we are employees you don't give W2s to
people who are non employees W2s only
exist for employees and that $200 we get
gets taxes taken
out you get your Medicaid and your
Social Security taxes taken out of that
$200 by the way at the time it was
established it was um enough it was
based on the average salary of the not
salary but income of a farmer at the
time and it was enough at the time to
buy four acres with a house so it was
always intended to be compensation for
employment having said that I want to
bring it back around so in the past
state legislators have applied for um
the fact that they have served an office
public office um to count towards their
public service for Public service loan
forgiveness that's been traditionally
sent to um Das and hold
on just want to check and uh the well
sorry the accounting office has
historically deced Ed not to certify
legislators applications when they were
asked because they said and I went
through a whole bunch of emails with
them they said it was on the basis that
they didn't consider us employees
because we were elected and served a
term rather than going through normal
hiring or firing processes I will point
out that we have a number of state
employees that are elected and do not go
through a normal hiring and firing
process for example the Secretary of
State the clerks of the various the two
Chambers and the state treasurer are all
elected positions yet they are
considered employees they get the same
Ein on their
W2 um and they qualify for for Public
forgiveness further the commissioner of
the Department of administrative
Services last year when we had this uh
Charles Arling house uh repeatedly
stated that he was fine and had no
reason to oppose the certification of
legislators so a few years back we
passed RSA 14 a Col 6 this allowed state
legislators access to employee benefits
while saying that this does not mean
that they're employees they're not
employees in terms of how the state
considers them they are employees for
how the feds consider us but we're going
to still give them access to employee
benefits we did that and in the same way
this would also give us that same access
to employee benefits um but while we did
that that actually cost a little bit
because they're covering us under the
EAP program there's some administrative
cost to uh even though we take on the
full amount for health insurance there's
some administrative cost there in
including us there's some cost there's
absolutely zero cost to Simply
certifying that we are operating in
public
service so the idea that we would want
to provide this for legislators is
important because right now we have a
body because of the volunteer position
the $100 a year where it's exceedingly
hard to get the average New Hampshire
person to run for office because if you
try to recruit the most people say oh
the great I'm very interested in running
for office how much does it
pay I'm sorry I can't quit my job I have
to pay my mortgage I have to pay my rent
it's very hard so what we have currently
is a body that does not look like the
rest of the state it is older wider and
most importantly richer than the rest of
the state it's not representative the
way the House of Representatives is
supposed to be and I think in order to
pass legislation that looks that that
reflects the will of the people we need
to have a body that reflects the will of
the people and in order to do that we
can encourage younger people working AE
people to actually run for office by
providing these very small free benefits
again it doesn't cost us anything and
it's the least of the ass just say hey
the service that I've provided here
counts for public service because we all
to call ourselves public servants we say
that proudly but we're not going to
sense so not only does it not cost New
Hampshire any money whatsoever but New
Hampshire is a federal income donor
State meaning our tax dollars um don't
come back to us in federal services in
the same amount that we send them out
other states are beneficiaries of our
federal tax dollarss from our workers
which means because of of the 19 States
I am currently aware of 17 of them
certify their state representative
Service as public service including
states that have what they consider to
be part-time
legislatures and even legislatures that
only meet once every two years but they
certify their
service so that means our State dollars
are going to forgive Mass Metts
legislators California
legislators but not our own legislators
who don't even get
paid now I do want to bring up the
question of okay you know is it really
full-time service because we are a
part-time legislature our session only
lasts half the year because when it was
created in this way most people were
farmers so they actually and they had to
travel by horse they came all the way in
stayed for half the year and would go
back to their
Farms so
we are a part-time legis legislature but
at no point are you an off-duty
legislator you never get to take off
your role as a state rep if you get
arrested the newspapers don't say off
duty State Rep they say State Rep you
are always 100% every second of the day
accountable to your voters for every
action you take whether it's here or
anywhere
else I answer constituent emails texts
and phone calls at all hours of day all
days of the year weekends I this past
Christmas I at 11:00 at night on
Christmas Eve was helping a constituent
and in contact with the
constituent so we are full-time
legislators even though session is
legislature so yes the majority of
States already give this
um validation validation is what it's
not even a benefit it's just validating
our service almost all the states
already do that certainly of the ones
that the vast majority of the ones that
um I've been able to get information
on um including our neighboring states
uh there's a whole I think the house
clerk has a a more comprehensive list
than I
do and I just want to bring that this
piece back around to the idea that the
whole point of the pslf program under
George W Bush was to incentivize young
people into public service we not doing
that with the income here right we don't
do that we keep retired people here we
don't help working people to get into
this place to affect change in ways in
ways that would resonate with that
people like them the least we can do is
say well if you're going to serve an
office then this is public service um
and we desperately need that kind of
representation here as for the second
part of the bill um it is similar to
something you've already heard I've
personally gone through this I know
other legislators have gone through this
so what this is is that if you are a
working person and you're trying to
serve an office right now your employer
can keep you from coming here and in my
case my employer absolutely kept me from
showing up to a session day where the
headliner bill was something that he
absolutely knew he disagreed with me on
it was a gay uh rights issue he
absolutely disagreed with me and
prohibited me from showing up so I don't
know why we're allowing employers to
affect legislative outcomes that way
when in fact a police officer cannot
detain us on our way to session when in
fact the speaker can force us our compel
our attendance it hasn't happened in any
kind of recent time but can compel Us by
force can send police officers to pick
us up and bring us into session that is
how sacred our constitutional duty to
this body is that we say we can actually
take away your bodily autonomy and force
you in here because you agreed to serve
in public office and jury duty is
covered as a protected reason to miss
work we get out of jury duty if we have
session on the days we're supposed to
serve yet our employer who has to give
us time off for jury duty doesn't have
to give us time off for this place even
though this place supersedes jury
duty so I don't know why we're allowing
employers to do that when this is an
unpaid day off they can require that an
employee in this bill can require an
employee use their paid time off that
they've AC Creed if they've accured any
um and they have to give a two-day
notice ahead of time to let because we
only get a minimum of three-day notice
for hearings and what have you um so
this would be a two-day notice to the
employer otherwise you would not be
covered and that's the entirety of the
bill like I said two different pieces
both affect the idea that we want more
working age Working Class People in this
body to represent
what actual people in New Hampshire look
like that is how they're connected but
I'm happy to take questions thank you
for your testimony are there any
questions yeah represent thank you are
you thank you re Reed are you you gonna
submit anything written no I just have
my own personal notes but I'm happy if
you would like me to I can kind of give
you like the bullet points but it's not
in a written testimony format that would
be helpful sure because you said a lot
which is good stuff but just keep it all
wall thank you very much Madam chairman
and thank you for your testimony
representative Reed um did I hear you
correctly it said 17 other states allow
this of the 19 that I have researched
because I personally am a member of two
national organizations of state
legislators um ncel and the national
women's legislator um yeah whatever so I
go to these conventions so I've I've
developed connections with other state
legislators so I went through all of my
connections um and of these 19 states
that I was able to find out information
on 17 of them definitely do certify
Public Service followup including
part-time part-time and one out of every
two-year uh legislators legislator okay
uh thank you clarify for me in case I
didn't hear correctly you to talk very
fast and you had a load of information I
apologize thank you um so you said they
certify these employees um does that
mean these employees who have not earned
time off do get time off to so those are
two different pieces of the bill the
first piece is saying that us as state
Reps for the purposes of the Public
service loan forgiveness program which
is a federal program under George W bush
that after 10 years of ontime payments
while you are working in Public Service
um you get the rest of your loans
forgiven all as far as I can tell almost
all the other states do this for their
legislators but we don't and we're
saying this is the least you can do is
just certify a piece of paper that's
saying yes you you served in public
service from whenever you swore in to
whenever you left office that's
literally all that piece is asking for
the second piece the second piece which
is
related the second piece which is
related through the idea that all of
this bill is trying to make it easier
for younger working people to serve the
second piece is an employer employee
employee protection for a legislator
saying that you get your employer cannot
discipline you if you give them two days
in in advanced notice that you have to
attend session or a hearing or a
committee that you are a member of or a
hearing on a bill that you sponsor of
got it thank you sorry for the
confusion any other questions rep away
thank you madam chair uh so my question
is in regards to those other states that
have uh that allow their legislators to
count this towards Public Service did
they have to do that through legislation
or um was it just evaluated differently
from the federal level um that they
consider that full-time service because
you mentioned the reason they denied New
Hampshire rep is that it's an elected
position and not hired through TR
traditional means I'm just wondering are
those other states doing this through
legislative means so as far as I'm aware
the vast majority did not have to pass a
law because they were just getting their
service certified actually most other
states do don't have this weird argument
because most of them get paid at least a
stien level so they don't have this
weird like we're a volunteer legislature
argument that we're not actually
employees so they are considered
employees in most other states even if
they're only getting like $115,000 as a
stipend which sounds like a lot for us
right but that's not a lot for other
reps um I think California is in the six
digits Massachusetts I think is up to
90,000 but Tennessee I know is like the
$155,000 range um so and there are other
states that do pay very little or per
DMS but I think that we are officially
the least paid um so having said that
most of them do kind of don't have this
argument that you're not really an
employee of the state they kind of
already are um in terms of the part-time
full-time thing they haven't
administratively just haven't made up an
issue of that so they just certify the
you're you're a full-time legislator
regardless of how often session actually
happens you never stop being a
legislator um I there may be states that
did do it by law but as far as I know
they just didn't have to because they
weren't getting denied um what I said
was not any kind of official um like
thing but when I was going in emails why
were people being denied this particular
thing with the accounting office they
said that that was their rationale but
it wasn't like an official like it was
just what they said their rationale for
making that decision
was follow sure yeah thank you um and
have you reached out to um the uh Public
service loan forgiveness program to
confirm that this legislation would then
qualify um no because it really just
comes down to that form and for what
it's worth I did get my loans forgiven
which is why I feel no problems
sponsoring this because I have no dog in
the fight at this point um but they it's
it's a form that you give to all of your
Republic Service employers or anyone you
thought was a public service employer
they fill out their EIN number which is
how the feds know the Ein that they
would be filling out for us is the same
Ein as every other state employee which
qualifies the Ein qualifies it is on the
list our Ein on our W2 for our $200 is
on the list of qualifying Ein for the
federal government that says that this
is an EIN that if you have service under
this Ein you have employment under this
Ein you
qualify so anyone who gets that W2 with
that EIN number qual that time period
qualifies yeah thank you I'm sorry I
shouldn't should not recognize the
questions representative
Richards just to so was your the Ein
that you just said
qualified um from here part of your 120
is was it part of what you Cobble
together or did you no I have you had it
qualified through other means not
through thank you been a an adjunct
teacher at Community College I've been a
driver for public transit I have been a
teacher at other places I have a lot of
public service that qualified other than
the state
house but it before I got my loans
forgiven this would have increased the
time I had to qualify so it was a
conflict of interest for me that I think
maybe to put this in before that but now
that it's it's been forgiven and I don't
any longer have a dog in the
fight any other
much and I will call the clerk of the
Smith good afternoon long time to see um
Paul Smith Clerk of the house just here
uh to provide a couple of uh points of
of
clarification um again uh as
representative Reed said there's two
components of the bill um I have nothing
to say whatsoever about the second
component um I'm I'm here just to talk
specifically about the
pslf um and and the reason for that is
um as as you all know um I have
colleagues across the country there's 99
of us um there's not a 100 because
Nebraska is unicam legislature so um
that being said uh you know we
communicate on various issues um between
the states uh when we're looking for
information um they they just recently
uh sent me a request asking about
members desks and I I got a little
chuckled because you know you don't get
any of those um so I uh in turn asked
the question about pslf um and uh I I I
didn't receive responses from everybody
because not everybody participates um
however um I did receive uh a slew of
responses um and just as a as a brief
snapshot um although the term employment
is is sort of a contention a contentious
issue here um in terms of service
because this is Public service loan
forgiveness uh in terms of service that
counts uh the following states reported
to me that they do count the service
towards uh the pslf uh
program um so Florida Maine Hawaii
Vermont Pennsylvania
Virginia um Kansas Alabama Washington
Minnesota Texas uh California Wyoming in
Louisiana um all reported to me that
they do participate in pslf um in terms
of certifying their members Service as
uh as it counts towards uh the program
uh two states of that group of of that
responded responded no and that would be
Kentucky and New Mexico now
interestingly New Mexico does not pay
their members at all uh they have a
perdum but they do not have a
legislative salary whatsoever um so we
often comment about being the lowest
paid in the country uh but New Mexico
they whenever I'm at an ncsl meeting
they like to chime in and say oh no no
we're we're the we're the least okay um
but uh but anyway uh just so just for I
wanted to present that because again um
in a few of these cases as well um the
clerk uh certifies I know in this this
legislation uh it's written that the
clerk is to certify these these forms um
I myself um after uh 20 years after I
graduated college um I had the last
$44,000 of my student loans forgiven via
pslf I was grateful for that um but I
did go through
rgo um for that for that practice
however in several of these states the
clerk does certify um on behalf of of
the
legislators um so that's I just wanted
to give you sort of a snapshot as as to
how the program um is run and again uh
representative Wade asked the question
earlier about legislation I I believe it
has been sort of um uh a decision of the
sort of chief administrative officers
with their HR folks that uh they came to
that decision on their own um about the
service because again it's not about
employment it's about the service um
because uh you know you can you can
you're
uh you could essentially um well I I'll
just call it that it's it's the service
that that counts in that um in that
respect
so thank you for your testimony are
there any
questions R um just quick question so um
from what you just said uh it's the
service that's at issue um for the
reason for denying some of these claims
so in your view does this
legislation um would would that fix that
uh because it's a federally administered
program right um so would this state
law actually work as intended um for
from your understanding uh I think so um
certainly um that you know by by stating
the position of uh that that you all as
the legislative body believe this is
important enough to count for this
program uh it it certainly gives
direction to the legislative staff but
because this one actually um directs me
to fill out the form you know I I would
take the message loud and
clear representative P thank you madam
chair um so the list of states that you
mentioned did they pass a law to have
their legislators qualify or did they
just do it right so as I mentioned uh in
response to representative Wade's
question I believe that in many of these
cases it was sort of a determination by
their cheap administrative uh folks um
to to process these on their own without
legislation okay I I think the rationale
here is because um because there's this
question and and and it is a
long-standing question um I I want to
make it clear that before the pslf
program began um there's always been um
we've had we've had members uh that used
to appear before this committee a lot
when they were alive representative
marpel for example that used to talk
about the fact that he was not an
employee and that's why he deserved to
be paid his compensation in gold and
silver and and that sort of thing uh
because he was an elected official um so
so that argument has been around a very
long time and I think that's why uh gcio
uh has sort of uh Gone by that that
long-standing provision but setting a uh
setting the the position uh in law that
this this does count I I think that
addresses that just follow please so the
administrators of the general
court could they just reconvene and
reassess without us pass having to pass
a law I
I I I'm my best advice to you is that if
uh that that would be a very good
conversation for you to have uh with
those folks however based on the
precedent of of of Prior decisions um I
likely okay any other questions seeing
none thank you oh rep wall
sorry much M Madam
chairman so are there penalties in other
states if employers don't allow this
time
off uh so I'm I'm not talking about that
part of the bill um I truly have nothing
to say about that that's entirely uh I I
wasn't asked to to look at that and I'm
that's
okay okay
thanks right no other questions thank
you very
much and I have one more pink card John
Jan
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee uh my name is John garan I am
general counsel at the Department of
Labor um the department is neutral on
this bill I'm just here to provide some
information um really on the enforcement
piece um for the employment um or the
the non- discharge part I I we don't
take any position on Public service loan
forgiveness um just so you're aware um
under our laws under RSA
27311 a um a violation of of of this
proposed language here that would result
uh for a first time in a warning um with
30 days to correct and then any
subsequent violations could be
punishable by up to a $2500 civil
penalty um I had come before the
committee a few weeks back and
previously testified on HB 347 which is
a very similar bill um the testimony we
had on that bill was
uh that bill was seeking to amend RSA 14
UHA and our our our position was that we
needed um language amended into that
bill in order to give us authority to
not just penalize but to also
investigate um and to look into these
instances um this bill HB 605 um takes a
different tack it actually includes the
violation within RC 275 which is our
kind of main protective legislation uh
statute at the Department of Labor um as
such this bill we feel actually properly
has an investigative Authority and the
penalty Authority in it so we don't have
any technical corrections to suggest on
that front I just want to clarify the
difference in position between those two
bills um so this language addresses all
the concerns that we had raised with HB
questions representative P thank you
madam chair did you just say 275 because
I I'm reading 270 oh wait a minute now I
thought I said 273 no yes can you
clarify 275 versus 273 yeah absolutely
yeah so uh RC 273 is the establishing
statute for the Department of Labor um
I'll back up one step the Department of
Labor administers a lot of statutes um
one of that happens to be RC 273 that's
our kind of establishing statute that's
the kind of core um it's a very old
statute goes back to 1911 um and some
instances goes back to 1894 when the
department was founded um among the
statutes we administer RSA 275 contains
I think what most people would typically
think of as like the wage and hour laws
like you've got to get paid on time um
employers are only allowed to deduct
certain things that sort of stuff so
this um this bill would propose adding
this right to leave work within that um
that statutory construction um that's a
statutory area that we do a lot of work
in we have a lot of jurisdiction over so
um with that Clarity in that this would
be an RSA 275 as opposed to trying to
amend rsa1 14a which the department has
no otherwise authority over rsa1 14a um
we feel that this would be a um a proper
kind of a good place for it if if the
intent was to have the department
provision any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony and we have no
other pink cards so I will close the
there's
chair will open the hearing on hr8 and
recognize not the prime sponsor but you
are introducing the bill I am
introducing the bill on representative
belcher's behalf my name is
representative Len turkot I represent uh
towns of barington and straford straford
County District 4 here to introduce
house resolution number eight resolving
that the practice of suspending a
constitutional officer to be outside the
authority designated to the Judiciary
and appropriate appropriately delegated
to the general court uh I am introducing
this on representative bel's uh behalf
he unfortunately finds himself
hospitalized today and is still in the
hospital so I I don't know enough about
his bill to speak to it but there it is
so you'll take questions then right
absolutely bring them
on thank you uh representative um we
have I would like um pink cards but we
don't have any um I can tell you a
and sure they pink card
[Music]
it's a Well oil machine today we've got
going
um I will U pass on some information for
you
um from what I know um this bill deals
with
um the New Hampshire Supreme Court and
their
um uh
decision to put uh one of the justices
on I'm not even sure if this is the
right term pay leave or something like
that um so the question is
whether the court has that ability and
to what extent does that
ability as it goes longer does that
um turn into a virtual I'm making this
up a virtual impeachment of that of that
Justice because by
constitutional um analysis or reading
only the legislature has that ability to
do
impeachments
so that's the gist of what this is
about layered on top of that is the
concern of mine that house resolutions
as as we've learned from last term um
house resolutions only are dealt with in
the house they don't go to the Senate
so it's kind of um I'm not sure what
this is going to accomplish the last
piece that I'll give you and explain to
you that you'll be receiving an email
from me is some information that I
received
from um attorney Cy house councel that
um refers to a case um in New Hampshire
where the court in their decision
discussed this this concern of um does
the court have room to discipline and at
what point does discipline turn into
something other than discipline and um
so I will provide all of that
information for you and we will use it
at some point um for the exact session
um I'm hopeful that the prime
sponsor um recovers and is able to speak
for himself I I will certainly provide
him some time if we need it during the
exec session but um but he is the only
sponsor as you see on here and it makes
it awfully difficult for us um so um as
it stands that's where it stands right
now and that's about all I can tell you
so with that I'm going to close the
house resolution
8 and our last piece of business for the
day is a hearing on the non- gerain
amendment which I'm going to ask
introduce so I'll open up the
um hearing
on House Bill 118 which is a non- gerain
Amendment thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Len turkot I represent
the towns of barington and straford
straford County District 4 uh I'm here
to put in an amendment for
hb18 uh re uh replacing the title of the
bill and the entirety of the
bill and act repealing certain
committees and
commissions since it is representative V
okay and that's all I have to say that I
will not take any questions on it thank
you very much uh representative turot um
I will again give you a little
explanation here um this committee
especially for those that are not
familiar with this committee um I don't
don't know how many years we've done
this um started with the original four
with the original comcom committees back
um with a a prior researcher that we had
U who was brilliant named Pam smling um
we have
within our house RSA Our House and
Senate
rsas somewhere in the neighborhood of
three to 400 committees and commissions
um it's a daunting task to
um to staff or to um what's the word I'm
looking for um popul populate um those
uh those committees and commissions and
in the process um our Deputy um speaker
uh assistant Deputy speaker comes across
ones that need to be have either outlive
their usefulness and never were drafted
uh with an expiration date attached to
them or um they have not met in years
and and no one can decide whether they
need to be uh in existence any longer
and so we end up with this list in this
case of 10 or 11 I think something like
that of of
um
suggested um
repeals and so this is a hearing to um
hear from anyone that would like to
speak about um any of these committees
or commissions and whether or not uh
they should be removed um from
consideration for uh for continued
Staffing or um populating so uh with
that that's about all I can tell you
about it and uh with that I'm I
have these are the two that were up
there was that right so I have two U
Maryanne can I correct some of the this
so that it um might it can get into the
record barter it is b a r t r yes thank
you okay um if you'd like I can Shannon
Trembley to join me and then you could
get us both done at once uh no uh we're
fine go as we go um you are with the New
Hampshire Child Care advisory Council
yes I'm currently the chair Okay C chair
um welcome to legislative Administration
and
uh tell us about your organization thank
you so um we were surprised to see
ourselves on this list because we have
been very busy and very vibrin for
several years well for decades now uh
the childcare advisory Council meets um
six times a year year we have a voting
membership of voting and non non- voting
members we have we get reports from DHHS
and from the Department of Education and
then we report back with suggestions
that might um or we advise on anything
that might impede access to child care
Statewide so when I think of the child
care advisory Council I really think of
a group of people who are trying to do
what's best for the children trying to
make sure that parents have access to
child care and try to make sure the
childcare providers remain open vibrant
and serving their communities so what we
have really done over the last several
years during the pandemic is make sure
that the child care providers are aware
of all the different options that are
open to them the different funds that
are available um different ways to
access these funds and we've also
reached out to DHHS and the Department
of Education about any information or
anything pending that might impede the
ability to provide child care and I will
use as an example of some of the work
we've just finished is the childcare
advisory Council convened a group of 11
child care providers to work with um
DHHS dhs's licensing childcare Licensing
Bureau to get together and to go through
the rules line by line it took us almost
a year it was an incredible process but
to streamline the rules to make it
possible for child care providers to
continue to provide care in the state
and not be so overburdened by regulation
um it is a heavily regulated industry
we're thinking about kids safety we want
to make sure the childcare licensing
rules are about children's safety and
not hidden quality agendas or hidden
other agendas uh that would impede
access uh we do have to rep present a
report to the house oversight committee
once a year we did that in June and I do
it yes I really don't unless anyone has
thank you Mr chair do you have any idea
or does anyone have any idea how you
your group ended up on this list no I
wish I knew I mean we we don't we don't
know I
mean sometimes in doing our work we
irritate
people okay so I might be able to shed a
little light
um first off um can I ask how many
voting members and how many non- voting
members you have I would defer that to
Shannon she's the director of the
childcare advisory
Council yeah off the top of her head
18ish it's not a very tight committee
I'm gonna I'm going to be honest we have
not looked at our bylaw since
2002 2011 and the world of child care
has changed dramatically in that period
of time um we are currently going
through the strategic planning process
we hired a consultant from St an College
to interview stakeholders interview
members of um the childcare advisory
Council different Community leaders to
kind of understand how the childcare
advisory Council can serve communities
today and serve the the state today um a
perfect example of the change in the
childcare advisory council is for the
very first time we have someone from the
Bia who's attending our meetings because
we know the future of child care is
child care providers providing a service
so employers can have employees and
building that close relationship will
really and formalizing that close
relationship will benefit both the
Employers in the state and child care
facilities thank you um I have read your
bylaws um and and a couple of the things
that I think may have triggered this and
and I again I'm only making this up but
I'm trying to answer your question
um in in the voting members there is one
um representative and one
Senator
um but there's a number of voting
members within this organization so from
I think from this perspective there's
not very much input from the legislative
side of things so the question is why
are we having a um a
legislative enact did study committee um
when it's not really legislatively
driven this so I think part of the
question and and again this is this is
supposition on my part part of the
question is does this
operate um if there if those two line
items one for house and one for Senate
didn't didn't participate and could
everything still operate the way it does
outside with them um determining any
changes and them reporting back to um
either DHHS or HHS or or children and
family law or whoever it is without the
the input of the legislator of the
yep uh thank you Mr chair for my
question would that be why in this uh
the language of all the different
different lines that we have um there's
relative to and in this instance um and
then there's also relative to the
repeal and so therefore underline eight
on page two it says relative to The
Advisory Council on child care but it
does not say relative to the repeal so
therefore it's seeking that further
clarification
I think
it yeah I I I think this is almost
turning into a work session here and
we're trying to piece it together and
and I'm not sure are repealed yeah it
does have the repeal okay thank you but
I'm not
um um I'm not
entirely certain of my Spiel a minute
ago um but I also will say that um uh
we've got two extraordinary things the
two people that know most about this um
and we don't plan on um voting on this
or anything today thank you but um but
the two people um coincidentally uh with
the the last qu are all part of either
in the hospital are have been sick all
weekend or now um our our vice chair is
having to um exec up in Edna her second
committee so the the people um that know
most about this aren't here so um we're
kind of at a loss we're kind of working
on on
supposition representative wall thank
you Mr chairman I'm still trying to get
some information on this please um you
meet six times a year correct do you
offer any reports to anybody anywhere
yes so we have um we tape the the
meetings and in case anyone can't make
it we have our minutes that are on both
of our website and on the Early Learning
New Hampshire website we were um do
announce our meetings in the calendar
the state and the legislative C
calendars and um we report the house
oversight committee once a year so but a
lot of the reporting back is um is
suggestions so um for example someone
from the Child Development Bureau might
call us and say what is the field
feeling about X Y and Z and then we may
go back and do some fact finding and
figure out and then report
out thank you follow up thank you very
much Mr chair and thank you um the vice
chair and I served on the committee to
get rid of commissions that were
dormant and not meeting frequently at
all and not offering reports so you are
meeting six times a year you are who do
you give your reports to again please
that host over site committee and I do
have copies of our most recent report
right here that's very helpful thank you
you thank you Mr chair um so you stated
that there is one house rep and one
Senator on your committees do they
attend the six meetings a year I'd love
to say they do but they do not um
Senator Whitley was very active on our
committee and she did attend during her
tenure um we haven't had luck getting a
leg getting a house representative to
attend in quite a long
time part
of part of that my understanding is I
think your meetings are Thursdays yes um
oh yes we have a which is a house
session day um so um to be fair it
doesn't it you know just to explain a
little bit why Thursdays may not or
attendance may not be what you had
hoped um
but again I think part of it is not c
not certain whether there's a
need um representative shott you had a
question I
did thank you Mr chairman uh just one
quick Point somebody was asking about on
line 25 on the first page it talks about
repeal the following are repealed and I
would agree the way it's written when
you get towards the back they're talking
about
repeals I don't know if we're repealing
a repeal or what's going on so I think
there's that needs to be looked at um to
the speaker um did you say you were the
chair of this advisory Council yes thank
you followup M
um besides doing that do you work in in
the business of child care yourself and
what is that that you do sure thank you
for asking um so I am the chair of
childcare advisory Council but I do not
get any renumeration for that the my day
job is I'm the executive director at
marac Valley daycare service and
blueberry Express Daycare um so I have
area I'll follow up on that um of if you
can get for us the voting members and
the non- voting members somewhere along
the line um and and any indication of
how many of the voting members and non-
voting members are in the child care
business would be helpful
um further represent thank you Mr
chairman thank you
um If This Were to be
repealed and you report to Health and
Human
Services does Health and Human Services
have the authority to set up their own
doing can I be very candid um it's just
us here the YouTube
so perhaps but I will say that child
care providers individual child care
providers do not have a very strong
voice in New Hampshire so and a lot of
things get done to us without our
consult consultation right so um I would
say our licensing regulations have
always been incredibly cumbersome we
were glad to tackle that some of the
arpa funding that went through DHHS
we frankly disagreed with um how those
funds were being used um some of the
ccdf plans the quality initiatives which
is the QRS if anyone's everever heard of
that um we've frankly really disagree
with that so um my concern would be if
HHS developed their own Council it would
be to promote
HHS um agendas and I I know that sounds
negative love them we work closely with
them they're great Partners but truth of
the matter is we argue with them a lot
because we're about what it looks like
not ideally not in a perfect world but
what it looks like realistically to do
this work in this per in this
environment in our state and it's
frustrating when State leadership does
not hear the fact that sometimes a
zoning law or sometimes something that's
very well-intentioned can completely
decimate a a business and that's why
it's so important that they providers
have a voice followup followup thank you
very much and thank you for your
explanation
um I know you have one Senator and one
State Rep on this council do you either
call in other elected officials to meet
with you and do you or if do you have
individuals file legislation on the
council's behalf we have not had them
file leg legislation on the council's
behalf we have recommended legislation
that has had some
legs I needed that clarification also so
you do have legislators who are involved
even though they're not members
of and as far as um when we think of
providers not being voting members our
meetings um are in public but we also
have a zoom option and we also have an
evening option for people who can't be
there but might still have questions um
we have sometimes over 200 people child
care providers going to our meetings and
listening to the things that are
happening there it is a very engaged
Council so well so do I understand then
that you do actively have involvement
with legislators on a regular basis we
do thank you we met with representative
you no other questions thank you very
much thank you very much
um represent uh
representative Shannon trumbl do you
also okay welcome to legislative
Administration thank you Shannon tremble
um I'm here as the Director of the
childcare advisory Council um to answer
your question about the voting members
There are
16 um and we have three non-voting
members um from
DHHS and um The Bureau childcare
licensing um
I don't know if you have any more
questions or if I can add anything I'm
sorry um can you uh the last slide zero
members three voting
members non voting three non- voting and
then you said something with zero in it
um none none in the chair Child Care
industry or something like maybe nope
Department of Health and Human Services
licensing okay so they
they work for child care licensing I
get
right yeah
yes
um one of the other things that I saw in
your in your bylaws that kind of struck
me odd especially from the standpoint of
a legislative um committee established
was the fact that
um uh you can basically add members on
your own um you have the ability to um
um add to your normally a legislative
committee lays out who's going to be in
it um this one says or anyone else that
you choose um you can welcome them into
the committee so I'm I'm certain you
didn't always have 19 I think you've
added people as you go um that's unusual
for a for a legislative committee um so
that that was just another audity and
why I what triggered my question of how
many members you have at this point um
is do you have other testimony that you
would like to add to no I don't think so
questions for now thank you um anything
else I think we're all set thank you
very much perfect thank
you um with that I have no other pink
cards I have does anyone else want to
testify that's in the room no we're good
um as far as I can see there's no one
else and no one has contacted me from
any of the other groups with the
exception of the
offshore now I can't find
it yeah um offshore wind industry
development re
I believe that there's another piece of
legislation that's either coming up this
week or in the calendar that deals with
that so that may that may be coming off
um along the way but other than that um
what what we will do as a committee is
meet with um Deborah Charles and before
we exec any of these things uh and we'll
find out what the information is um as I
get any more information I'll certainly
provide it to the committee yep child I
don't know the name deor Childs is the
uh
Deputy
um um chief chief yeah a deputy chief of
staff Deputy Chief of Staff okay yeah
thank you
um what on you yeah don't well there's
there's between assistance assistant
such and such and deputies such and such
and assistant to the clerk and uh I'm
I'm I'm at the end of a day um but I
think um I think we've
got some things to discuss it'll be a
lively um um executive session I have
just one of the reason I jumped out of
here was to create the exec session
before the calendar deadline so um we've
set that up for
the 12th of
um Wednesday yeah unless that changes
yep what
nine and and I have not set it up just
for your purposes
um and not withstanding um being
ostracized for this but I set it up at 9
o' and we're just going to go until
we're done um we can recess at any
period of time and take a take a u lunch
break if we want to we can do but
they're not set times all the way
through what's our deadline for getting
reports out um now that we've
accomplished our our early bill um our
our next deadlines uh are all
320 okay so we are we're close we're
close and and we still have the concern
that uh the 12 turns into
a um a session day and if that's the
case uh be be mindful of me going to the
well um at one of
the um house sessions so that we can um
that will count as a
calendar um notification of when we're
moving things to so um I don't think we
would have time to get it in the
calendar if they come back and say on
the 12th we're having a session day um
quickly yeah
so so instead of putting it in the
calendar you can satisfy the public
notice public notice by
um by publicly stating it at the well
when when we will meet so but I will
with a small committee I will make sure
so yeah it won't be that
day
um what I'm hearing is if we're meeting
if we have that many bills that stack up
and have to be handled we will be
days if if we get to that point I mean
it it may even be
the H yeah it may even be the following
week which is the deadline right because
the 12th so it would be the 19th and
20th it may be that week so I'm hope
actually sounds terrible but I am
hopeful it's that rather than screwing
up our schedule for getting out on the
but we will need um we will need reports
quickly for that as well so the good
part about a lot of our bills we have
reports already written um so um from
prior years that we've done this so you
pretty much can just pull I think at
least five of these I think we've
already heard so so assuming the results
are the same uh anything else anybody
104 adios thanks for everybody for today